voilà on a retrouvé le rapporteur donc
nous pouvons commencer notre audition
mesdames et messieurs donc nous
poursuivons aujourd'hui notre amour par
une table ronde sur les fraudes à la
rénovation énergétique nous recevons 5
acteurs concernés à différents titres
par la fraude et par l'escroquerie dans
la rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
en tout premier lieu la direction
générale de la concurrence de la
consommation et de la répression des
fraudes chargée notamment de réprimer la
fraude à la rénovation énergétique
représentée par Monsieur romain Roussel
sous-directeur industrie santé et
logement et Madame Miyako Guy chef de
bureau immobilier bâtiment et travaux
publics l'entreprise specty représentée
par son président et co-fondateur
monsieur
Oussama Jedi votre entreprise qui a été
créé en 2001 est un tiers de confiance
dans la rénovation énergétique disposant
de l'accréditation du COFRAC Comité
Français d'Accréditation dans le cadre
du dispositif des certificats d'économie
d'énergie des C2E vous réalisez ainsi
des inspections d'opérations
standardisées d'économie d'énergie la
revue Le Moniteur hebdomadaire du
bâtiment et de la construction
représentée par Monsieur Pierre Picher
journaliste et rédacteur en chef du
moniteur des artisans revue spécialisés
dans l'actualité des artisans du
bâtiment à ce titre vous avez mené en ce
début d'année une large enquête sur la
fraude à la rénovation énergétique qui a
souligné la diversité des méthodes
frauduleuses employées
l'association des commerçants
UFC Que Choisir représenter par Monsieur
Michel debiers administrateur national
et Madame Lucile buisson chargée de
mission environnement énergie et
transport
c'est pas commerçant c'est consommateur
et j'ai dit oui et pourtant c'était bien
écrit consommateur je suis désolé mais
bon
enfin l'association nationale de défense
des consommateurs et
usagers consommation logement et cadre
de vie plus connu sous l'appellation de
CLCV qui est représenté par Monsieur
David Rodrigue juriste secteur habitat
mesdames et messieurs dans vos
différentes fonctions que je viens de
rappeler vous avez eu l'opportunité de
constater l'ampleur de la fraude à la
rénovation énergétique et même
concernant la DGCRF de concevoir et de
mener des politiques de lutte contre la
fraude dans un contexte d'accélération
de la rénovation énergétique la fraude
et l'escroquerie jette un discrédit sur
l'ensemble de la politique publique en
remettant en cause le bien fondé de la
dépense publique et en entraînant une
perte de confiance chez le consommateur
votre audition dans le cadre de cette
table ronde doit nous permettre de mieux
comprendre ce phénomène ainsi que les
solutions qui peuvent être apportées
comment expliquer vous que les fraudes
qu'il s'agisse d'arnaque pur et simple
ou de malfaçon soit si nombreuses et
apparemment si peu sanctionner qu'elle
doit être selon vous l'équilibre entre
massification des rénovations et lutte
contre la fraude doit-on se résigner à
la multiplication des cas de fraude au
nom de l'accélération de la rénovation
énergétique enfin comment selon vous
peut-on améliorer l'efficience des
dispositions de lutte contre les
différents types de fraudes avant de
vous laisser la parole pour répondre à
ses premières questions pour un propos
introductif alors vous verrez partirez
le temps de parole comme vous le
souhaitez dans l'ordre que vous
souhaitez d'environ une quinzaine à
minutes il me revient de vous indiquer
que cette audition est diffusée en
direct et en différé sur le site
internet du Sénat et qu'un compte-rendu
sera publié je dois également vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête serait
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende
je vous invite donc les uns après les
autres si vous voulez bien vous prêter à
ce formalisme à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité a
levé la main droite et à dire je le jure
on commence par vous monsieur Roussel
voilà je vous en remercie très
sincèrement donc je vous laisse la
parole peut-être que c'est la DGCCRF qui
va débuter et après peut-être qu'on
suivra l'ordre d'installation autour de
cette table et à l'issue de vos prises
de parole à la fois pour répondre
peut-être à mes premières questions et
puis pour voilà faire un petit peu un
état des lieux si vous le voulez bien
sur la fraude à la rénovation
énergétique et les moyens de lutte
contre cette fraude ensuite bien sûr
notre rapporteur vous posera un certain
nombre d'autres questions ainsi que les
membres de la commission d'enquête qui
sont présents avec nous pour cette
audition donc je vous laisse la parole
monsieur Roussel et Madame Guy
[Musique]
sur la plateforme signal conso que nous
avons lancé en 2021 à la DGCCRF et qui
permet de aux consommateur de signaler
en fait les litiges qu'ils ont avec les
avec un certain nombre de professionnels
c'est un des secteurs qui ressort le
plus fortement avec plus de 10000
plaintes enregistrées l'année dernière
dans ce secteur donc c'est effectivement
un secteur qui génère de lourds de
lourds contentieux
des difficultés d'une certaine gravité
nous avons pu constater effectivement au
fil des différentes enquêtes que nous
avons pu mener et intensifier au fil des
années que c'était quelque chose qui
était effectivement un phénomène assez
massif et assez difficile à endiguer car
il est très adaptatif en fonction en
fait des des différents dispositifs de
politique publique qui sont mis en place
au fil du temps
donc il faut savoir que la rénovation
énergétique ça fait partie des priorités
en fait de la DGCCRF dans le cas de son
plan national d'enquête qui est définie
chaque année par notre directeur ou
notre directrice générale et qui
consiste à donner un programme de
travail et d'action au service des
concentrés que dont nous disposons sur
le terrain à la fois en région et dans
les départements sur l'ensemble du
territoire français et ultramarins pour
combattre ces schémas fraude
et j'y reviendrai de manière concertée
avec d'autres acteurs de la sphère
publique
c'est d'autant plus prioritaire dans le
cadre de la transition écologique comme
vous l'avez souligné qu'effectivement le
bâtiment étant un des secteurs les plus
consommateurs et les plus émetteurs de
gaz à effet de serre ça a été identifié
par les pouvoirs publics comme étant
effectivement un des leviers
d'action la rénovation énergétique à
crédibiliser et dans laquelle il est
important suscité la confiance des
consommateurs et des rénovations de
qualité pour pouvoir atteindre nos
objectifs climatiques ambitieux qui ont
été fixés dans le cadre de la part de
l'accord de Paris notamment de 2015
très concrètement au niveau la DGCCRF
au niveau de notre plan d'action
l'adrénovation énergétique ça se traduit
par un nombre de contrôles assez
important avec des enquêtes souvent
assez lourdes sur le terrain qui qui
mène qui donne lieu à de nombreux
établissements qui sont visités avec une
montée en charge assez forte qui s'est
faite sur les cinq dernières années
puisqu'on est passé de d'un peu moins de
500 établissements visités en 2018 à un
objectif de 1200 pour l'année 2023 avec
une montée en charge progressive au fil
des années et une formation permanente
de nos enquêteurs assurés par le bureau
de miyakogi et par le réseau afférent
également afin de de former vraiment les
enquêteurs assez fraudes qui sont de
plus en plus complexes
un taux d'anomalie dans le secteur qui
est élevé alors par anomalie on entend
effectivement à la fois des manquements
faute de connaissances suffisante de la
part de professionnels en matière de
code de la consommation par exemple un
non respect de certaines dispositions
très contractuelles ou une application
insuffisante du droit de rétractation à
des faits qui peuvent être beaucoup plus
graves
qui peuvent confiner à l'escroquerie en
bande organisée et qui nécessite
l'intervention de différents services de
l'État en partenariat notamment avec la
gendarmerie avec les services de l'État
sur le terrain dans le domaine fiscal
dans le domaine de la fraude sociale
également
et voir des coopérations
transfrontalières
alors quand on anomalie donc dans le
domaine de la rénovation énergétique qui
est élevée qui tourne selon les années
entre 50% et 56% des établissements
visités alors c'est pas forcément un
taux je précise qui représentatif du
tout en moyenne puisque nous n'avons pas
de vision vraiment précise du tout moyen
puisque les enquêteurs en fait de la
DGCCRF sont amenés à faire un ciblage en
amont et à effectivement ciblé les
établissements et soit qui leur sont
signalés à travers les plaintes à
travers signal conso soit qui à travers
la prospection commerciale leur site
internet leur centre présenter des
anomalies donc c'est sans doute un
majorant de ce qu'on constate sur le
terrain mais néanmoins c'est un taux
élevé et avec des faits d'une certaine
gravité qui se traduisent chaque année
non seulement par des avertissements
mais par plusieurs centaines enfin par
exemple en 2021 le dernier bilan complet
que nous avons c'est 131 avertissement
11 la jonction administrative mais aussi
34 procès-verbaux administratifs et 89
procès-verbaux-pénaux et c'est un tour
de procès-verbaux à la fois
administratif et pénaux qui est très
supérieur à un moyen qu'on constate dans
les autres secteurs et ça s'explique par
le fait qu'effectivement les pratiques
qui sont constatées sont souvent assez
graves et peuvent mener à des à des
difficultés vraiment très sérieuses pour
les personnes qui en sont victimes à des
situations de surendettement avec par
exemple dans certains cas des crédits
cachés qu'il souscrivent sans le savoir
avec des travaux qui sont mal fait et
qui donc
leur donne leur ferme la droite le droit
à des aides publiques ultérieures à la
rénovation énergétique
et donc des situations parfois de
détresse de la part d'un certain nombre
de ménages donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose que nous prenons très au sérieux
au niveau des sanctions et pour lequel
elle a certainement d'évolution en fait
réglementaire et législative Inter ces
dernières années nous aide aussi à
durcir notre politique de sanction je
pense notamment
à la réforme du 24 juillet 2020 en
matière de démarchage téléphonique qui
interdit complètement en fait le
démarchage téléphonique dans le secteur
de la rénovation énergétique sauf qu'a
accepte d'exceptionnel lorsqu'il y avait
déjà en fait un contrat en cours avec
avec l'entreprise et qui ont multiplié
par 5 les montants maximum des amendes
en cas de en cas de manquement ça nous a
amené à prononcer un certain nombre
d'amendes qui dans certains cas
dépasse les 100 000 voir les 300.000
euros dans les cas les plus graves et à
généraliser un certain nombre de
politiques de saisie pénale des biens et
qui permet d'avoir une action
effectivement qui double l'action qu'on
peut avoir devant les tribunaux et donc
de saisir aussi un certain nombre de
biens de malfaiteurs avant qu'il ne
ferme leur entreprise ce qui est souvent
le cas c'est souvent le cas
d'entreprises éphémères qui ont une
durée de vie assez courte et qui ensuite
soit fil à l'étranger soit
se déclare en faillite et rouvre une
activité similaire sous un autre nom
donc ça la saisie pénale est un outil
auquel on recourt de plus en plus et qui
permet justement de d'arriver à
prendre la mesure du problème et avoir
apporter à ce nombre de réponses
adaptées néanmoins nous sommes bien
conscients qu'il y a un certain nombre
de limites dans la mesure où les
fraudeurs ont une grande imagination
c'est ce qu'on constate en permanence
dès qu'un nouveau système est créé
d'être public il y a effectivement un
nouveau type de fraude qui est généré et
qui fait en sorte qu'on doit en
permanence adapter nos méthodes adaptées
la formation de nos enquêteurs pour
traquer les nouveaux types de fraudes et
également développer les coopérations
inter-services ce qui est quelque chose
de très important qu'on a développé
assez fortement depuis quelques années
depuis notamment
la loi relative à l'énergie au climat de
2019 qui nous a permis de renforcer en
fait les échanges d'information entre
les principales administrations
concernées par la lutte contre la fraude
à savoir le
pot national des certificats d'économie
d'énergie la DGDDI donc les services de
la douane la dgfi les services fiscaux
et également des agences
Anna donc agent national de la divita la
dame et traque fin
évidemment aussi sur le plan local les
la gendarmerie la police nationale et
les polices municipales lorsqu'il y en a
donc effectivement c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est important pour
nous car ça permet d'accroître à la fois
la rapidité et l'efficacité des suites
que l'on peut prendre lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on constate des manquements ou
des anomalies sur le terrain
voilà donc il y a ces différents points
donc qui sont assez importants mais il
faut être conscient qu'effectivement
notre action à un certain nombre de
limites liées au fait que les fraudeurs
comme je vous disais ont beaucoup
d'imagination et contournent un certain
nombre d'obligations qui leur sont
faites par la loi à travers des
mécanismes trompeurs pour les
consommateurs et qui qui font en sorte
du coup que en fait on constate pas
forcément une décrue malheureusement à
ce stade du nombre de d'anomalies
constaté notamment en matière de
démarchage téléphonique puisqu'on
constate que qu'un certain nombre de
sociétés contournent la réglementation
par exemple en indiquant pas l'objet
véritable de le rappel ou le fait que
cet appel à une intention commerciale
ou en procédant à d'autres à d'autres
subterfuges de dissimulation de leur
identité de confusion volontaire avec un
certain nombre de services publics ou à
d'autres types de prospection au
porte-à-porte par exemple ou lors de
salon
de contaminer cette interdiction
sectorielle qui a été édictée par la loi
donc ça nous amène aussi à effectivement
durcir notre action en termes de
sanctions mais aussi à essayer de
prendre en charge plus en amont les
différents les différents problèmes afin
d'arriver à mieux y faire face
compléter un peu sur ce point sur
d'autres aspects de notre action et
peut-être présenter aussi les actions de
formation et de sensibilisation de
prévention qu'on peut avoir dans ce
domaine parce qu'on a aussi une action
préventive à la fois à destination des
consommateurs et des professionnels en
accompagnement de cette action
répressive on joue sur les différents
leviers
donc
je compléter le panorama déjà très très
fourni qui a été présenté par Romain
Roussel donc effectivement nous avons
renforcé significativement nos actions
ces dernières années
face à l'ampleur donc des fraudes
constatés
donc en complément sur
le volet répressif donc je effectivement
vous voulez revenir sur le fait que on a
bien
de mode d'action c'est-à-dire une action
le plus en amont possible de manière
réactive au moyen donc des saisies
pénales qui permettent effectivement
donc d'immobiliser juridiquement des
biens et des avoir de manière
conservatoire et ainsi neutraliser les
opérateurs concernés et donc un certain
nombre de procédures
puis effectivement aboutir et puis bien
entendu donc avec des suites qui peuvent
être donc des suites administratives
qu'on utilise donc beaucoup notamment
sur des pratiques qui sont liées par
exemple à des manquements
relatifs à l'information
précontractuelle ou aux démarches
téléphoniques et on a effectivement un
certain nombre d'exemples des sanctions
assez percutantes qui ont pu être prises
dans ce domaine et donc également donc
des des poursuites pénales et ce que
l'on relève effectivement c'est que les
parquets sont de plus en plus mobilisés
et prononce des sanctions qui sont assez
significatives notamment ça peut être
donc des peines d'emprisonnement
donc avec sursis ou non
qui sont assortis éventuellement donc de
sanctions pécuniaires
donc conscient que il y a quand même
une nécessité également
de sensibiliser les consommateurs
ou
risque qui peuvent se présenter à sur
leur chemin nous avons travaillé en lien
avec notamment le ministère de la
transition écologique
pour donc monter une campagne de
sensibilisation donc qui a été déployée
notamment en novembre 2019
face à l'affût important de plainte et
donc ces campagnes de sensibilisation
en par la suite en fait était complétée
alors de notre côté du côté de la dgcf
nous avons notamment des fiches que nous
mettons sur le site qui sont des fiches
pratiques
qui vise à expliquer très simplement
consommateurs quels sont notamment leurs
droits et les pièges à éviter et donc
nous avons récemment
donc mise à jour
ces fiches et par ailleurs donc voilà
nous sommes en train de travailler de
réfléchir avec le message transition
écologique
amplifier les efforts de communication
de proximité sur le terrain auprès des
consommateurs notamment des
consommateurs qui peuvent être dans une
situation
particulièrement vulnérable du fait de
leur isolement géographique notamment
dans certaines zones rurales on a pas
mal d'opérateurs qui sévissent et qui
profitent effectivement
de des vulnérabilités des des personnes
qui qui habitent donc dans ces zones et
donc nous avons effectivement
euh par ce biais là en tout cas essayer
de d'améliorer la prise de conscience
sur les réflexes à avoir notamment
donc un conseil qui est de s'orienter en
priorité vers le service public de la
relation énergétique France rénove pour
pouvoir obtenir de premier
renseignements sur la démarche en fait à
suivre pour pouvoir faire des travaux et
puis pour ensuite en cas de
concrétisation du projet notamment être
accompagné avec le dispositif mon
accompagnateur rénov donc voilà nous
avons effectivement de ce point de vue
là
pas mal amplifié en fait nos actions
et au sein donc de notre réseau nous
avons accompagné en fait la montée en
charge
des services d'enquête
comme Romain Roussel effectivement la
préciser donc en forçant la formation
donc nous avons effectivement
un programme de formation annuelle qui
est proposé et qui est qui associe
notamment un certain nombre de services
tels que l'ADEME Lana et également donc
le cerema qui nous apporte un appui
technique particulièrement
utile
notamment sur les caractéristiques
techniques et les performances des
équipements de rénovation énergétique ce
qui permet derrière
d'apprécier si les allégations qui sont
soutenues par les opérateurs
sont
vraies ou fausses quand aux économies
d'énergie que l'on peut de ces
équipements donc on a effectivement
ainsi pu
véritablement accompagné si je puis dire
le déploiement des travaux de rénovation
énergétique par une amplification de nos
contrôles donc pour vous donner une idée
donc depuis 2017
nous avons quasiment doublé en fait le
nombre d'opérateurs contrôlés
voilà donc on est passé de 352
établissements à 679 établissements en
donc voilà pour ce qui est des
principales actions que nous avons
menées pour faire face à la fraude
sur l'efficience alors pour la question
de savoir comment
articuler notamment
massification des travaux et lutte lutte
contre l'afrod
donc en réalité
une bonne partie on va dire de l'enjeu
se situe en fait en amont donc j'ai dit
c'est la sensibilisation des
consommateurs et donc un accompagnement
adapté puisque dans le secteur de
l'animation énergétique
il y a une grande asymétrie
d'information entre les consommateurs et
les professionnels les consommateurs
peuvent par ailleurs avoir à faire en
fait à différents types d'opérateurs
puisque le paysage et l'entreprise
évoluer de manière assez sensible ces
dernières années avec notamment une
diversification des acteurs et une
division des tâches on va pouvoir on va
retrouver en fait en début de processus
de commercialisation
des sociétés qui sont des sociétés
purement commerciales qui ont faire de
la collecte de données du démarchage
téléphonique et donc
notamment
sollicité donc les prospects et puis on
a effectivement l'autre bout de la
chaîne des professionnels des travaux en
tant que tel
et donc cette division des tâches peut
effectivement
complexifier on va dire la situation des
consommateurs puisque en cas de
difficulté
il est plus compliqué de savoir vers qui
se retourner et c'est bien sûr le
principe de la décision étage c'est de
dil en fait les responsabilités il faut
ajouter également que
dans ce paysage de structure qui sont
pour une bonne partie des structures
éphémères
on a en réalité un réseau d'acteurs dont
une partie en fait n'est pas localisé en
France et souvent en fait les donneurs
d'ordre agissent donc en dehors des
frontières nationales
et donc vont notamment
être à l'origine
de flux financiers
extrêmement rapides qui vont transiter
donc
de la part des comptes en fait qui sont
dans des pays dans des pays tiers c'est
ce qui explique la complexité des
enquêtes
donc romain roussal effectivement à
parler un peu plus tôt
voilà donc d'où effectivement
la nécessité de mettre beaucoup l'accent
sur la sensibilisation les consommateurs
et sur donc l'accompagnement et cela
jusqu'à la réception la réception des
travaux
voilà alors il y a un autre enjeu et en
nous sommes quelque part témoins
finalement d'un marché qui est en fait
un marché qui est en face transitoire
qui n'a pas encore atteint son degré de
maturité puisque
on a effectivement une inadéquation
entre d'une part la demande de travaux
qui est effectivement fortement portée
par les autorités publiques par le
gouvernement grâce à des aides et
d'autre part
donc une offre de service qui
aujourd'hui enfin une offre de service
fiable qui est encore en nombre limité
donc il y a véritablement
[Musique]
un enjeu à
développer la formation déployer des
plans de formation massifs pour que l'on
puisse avoir à terme sur le marché
davantage le professionnel bien formé
voilà donc ça c'est un sujet qui est
suivi par ailleurs
par le Ministère en charge l'emploi
et de notre côté nous avons notamment la
préoccupation que les compétences
acquises par les professionnels soit non
seulement des compétences techniques qui
sont absolument indispensables à la
bonne réalisation des travaux mais aussi
une connaissance des principes
essentiels du droit de la consommation
parce que l'on voit que c'est quand même
malheureusement une lacune récurrente
qui est observée dans le cadre de nos
enquêtes et qui est de nature à
fragiliser la relation de confiance
que les consomm
pourraient avoir dans les consommateurs
dans les entreprises donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle notamment nous
sommes très soucieux que dans le cadre
du processus de qualification RGE
puisse être prévu un module
sur le droit la consommation un module
qui soit bien entendu adapté aux besoins
et aux contraintes des entreprises mais
qui permettent de couvrir les principaux
points de faiblesse qu'on a pu relever
notamment dans le cadre des enquêtes
donc ce travail est en cours
dans le cadre du groupe fibat qui est
donc chargé de définir le programme de
formation pour les entreprises
candidates au label RGE ou qui sont
titulaires donc de ce label
donc voilà et donc par ailleurs
il nous semble également que
il est important que les programmes
d'aide publique
soit conçu de telle manière que il ne
puisse pas être trop attractif pour les
professionnels qui sont indélicats donc
voilà nous avons vu par le passé que le
programme d'isolation à un euro était
quand même générateur de fortement de
fortes de fortes plainte et
effectivement il faut que
les dispositifs puissent être conçus de
telle façon que ils permettent en tout
cas de protéger suffisamment les
consommateurs voilà et pour le reste
il nous semble bien entendu
indispensable de poursuivre nos efforts
de continuer à
notamment travailler en
bien
et trois avec les autres services de
l'État qui font des contrôles de manière
à trouver une bonne articulation dans
nos contrôles
et parce qu'on a effectivement des
expertises qui sont des expertises
complémentaires et donc des moyens
d'action
qui peuvent être tout à fait efficaces
typiquement on peut appréhender un
opérateur sous différents angles sous
l'anglais pratique commerciale sous
l'angle de la fraude fiscale
et éventuellement
éventuellement l'afro de social tout ça
doit pouvoir effectivement être prise en
compte et enfin et ça je l'ai déjà
mentionné les parquets commencent à se
mobiliser effectivement il est important
que cette dynamique se poursuive de
manière à ce que les contrôles puissent
aboutir avec des suites percutantes
et permettant en tout cas aux opérateurs
de comprendre les risques qui sont
encourus lorsqu'on ne respecte pas les
règles voilà
merci en tout cas pour cette exposé très
complet de votre part je laisse la
parole à Monsieur j'ai dit
[Musique]
un bureau de contrôle dans le cadre du
dispositif C2E donc notre rôle c'est de
contrôler des travaux de rénovation
énergétique une fois fait réalisé par
par des entreprises
le contrôle pour sur 4 thématiques
principales
une thématique qu'on pourrait appeler la
clarté de l'offre même si le relais un
peu limité de bureau de contrôle parce
qu'on arrive après les travaux soient
fait donc on regarde
d'un point de vue documentaire c'est les
délais type des rétractation et ont été
respectés est-ce que le particulier a
bénéficier de d'une information claire
sur ces devis
ce qu'on appelle un cadre de
contribution C2E c'est le c'est un
document qui spécifie le montant des
aides attribué par par l'obliger et puis
ce qu'il a sa disposition une facture et
d'autres documents techniques de
l'opération de deuxième critère c'est en
vérifie les critères d'éligibilité au
dispositif
pour prendre un exemple clair pour une
isolation on va regarder est-ce que la
résistance thermique minimale exigée par
par une fiche d'opération standardisée
respectée
ensuite on va regarder les paramètres de
calcul du C2E pour rester sur l'exemple
de l'isolation ça va être la surface
isolée donc c'est ce qui permet de
déterminer le volume ces deux œufs qui
qui sera génial à l'opération quand on
fait 100 m² et 200 m² et c'est pas c'est
pas la même chose et puis on va regarder
aussi la pérennité dans le temps des
performances et la sécurité de pour
l'ouvrage enfin de l'ouvrage et
évidemment pour pour les personnes alors
ce rôle là de bureau de contrôle dans le
cadre des C2E a été imaginé allez en
2017 2018 en complément au rôle que
quand les les différents organismes de
l'État pour traquer les non qualités
c'est un rôle avant de de déposer les
demandes de certificat d'énergie donc on
n'est pas dans la on est plutôt du coup
une fois que que enfin avant que le
certificat soit déposé alors c'est un
rôle qui a été imaginé avec avec un avec
une forte
indépendance et impartialité puisque le
l'État a sollicité enfin exiger que les
organismes faisant ce rôle là soit
accrédité par le coffrage avec un niveau
on appelle type a alors quand vous
prenez le référentiel coffrac désolé
d'être un peu technique mais le
référentiel coffrac est composé en trois
niveaux d'intensité vous allez du C qui
est le niveau le moins élevé qui a
adapté à un certain nombre de
fonctionnalités et jusqu'au niveau A qui
vous interdit tout lien d'intérêt avec
qui que ce soit dans dans le dans
l'industrie dans laquelle vous opérez
donc ils l'ont imaginé comme ça parce
que ben parce que le sujet était était
nécessairement
brûlant j'ai envie de dire parce que il
y a fraude était à ce moment là il a été
très généralisé et même pas ce moyen là
en amont on était en pleine isolation à
1 euro et et c'est salutaire comme comme
décision sauf que aujourd'hui alors
depuis les politiques de contrôle se
sont renforcés il y a indéniablement il
y a voilà il y a une pression de
contrôle avant d'épo qui est qui est là
avec des exigences qu'on pourra
détailler mais qui sont qui sont de
nature à éliminer les non qualités de
façon assez assez importante en revanche
le sol le le vrai bémol dans ce rôle là
et que je que je je
modestement je représente toute la table
c'est c'est les conflits d'intérêts qui
a pu se ce campus naître entre le bureau
de contrôle à qui on a acquis
initialement on a dit qu'il fallait
qu'il soit au top niveau en terme de en
termes d'indépendance et d'impatalité et
bah on a vu naître
à cause de flou parfois réglementaires
parfois d'absence de de texte clair et
parfois aussi de sophistication de
niveau de fraude et de et d'imagination
on a vu des bureaux de contrôle soit
être lié à des à des intérêts dans le
dispositif donc des intérêts
d'entreprises de travaux ou de
demandeurs de certificat d'économie
d'énergie mais aussi de contrôle qui
sont fraudes enfin qui sont tout
simplement des des fraudeurs eux aussi
et donc là
il y a une enquête du moniteur qui l'a
très bien documenté je pense que
monsieur pichert va revenir dessus donc
je vais pas je vais pas aller dessus et
et
en fait en quelque sorte qui se joue
c'est que on a demandé un rôle un bureau
de contrôle pour éliminer la non qualité
et et éliminer autant que faire ce peu
la fraude et on se retrouve avec une
partie de de de de de de de bureau de
contrôle qui
soit sont peut regarder voir complaisant
soit carrément c'est des c'est des
tamponneurs de fraude en quelque sorte
et du coup on se retrouve avec des
corridors de fraude qui sont qui vendent
de l'auditeur énergétique et demain et
demain potentiellement et j'en profite
pour pour attirer dans l'attention sur
le rôle que va avoir l'accompagnateur
Renov qui va atteindre qui va un acteur
central rien n'empêchera les mêmes
pratiques si s'il y a rien qui qui est
mis en face aujourd'hui on a des
corridors notamment qui qui sont qui
sont bien représentants dans la
rénovation globale qui vont d'un
auditeur peut scrupuleux faisant partie
de la même entité en fait en fin de
compte à une entreprise qui va faire des
travaux bâclés puis un un demandeur de
ces deux œufs qui qui veut s'acquitter
de de ces de ses obligations parfois
avec on est un étampe regardant un
bureau de contrôle qui va tamponner
parce que bah il fait partie du même
écosystème qui va tamponner ça sans
scrupule et et du coup un consomm qui a
un consommateur qui d'un côté
l'impression d'avoir d'avoir vu cinq
acteurs différents et d'avoir été en
quelque sorte protégé par par cela et ça
n'est pas le cas et en face on a aussi
une administration pnc2e qui a
l'impression d'avoir exigé tout ce qu'il
faut mais que le résultat n'est
évidemment pas là donc il y a vraiment
une il y a vraiment une moi il y a
vraiment un enjeu pour moi crucial qui
est qui est celui-là parce que c'est un
des outils de de la lutte contre la
fraude le le contrôle avant travaux
c'est pas le seul et ça doit pas être le
seul mais c'est un des outils et il faut
il faut lui exiger les mêmes le même
niveau d'indépendance que les agents de
l'État qui sont bien représentés ici il
ne faut pas qu'il y ait qui est des des
liens d'intérêt qui sont de nature à à
atténuer voir éliminer tout l'intérêt
qu'il peut avoir voir dangereusement à
donner l'illusion de d'une d'une
politique de contrôle qui n'est
finalement pas pas effectivement nous on
a mené une étude
sur les sur de notre rôle de bureau de
contrôle amené une étude on a fait un
retour d'espérance sur sur 36000
inspections qu'on a mené au cours de
2021 et 2022 c'est 36000 inspections qui
portent sur
à peu près 400 000 chantiers parce qu'en
fait on échantillonne un échantillon
aléatoire et on le contrôle donc c'est
36000 déplacements sur ce site pour pour
être très concret qui porte sur 400 000
qu'ils ont représentatif de 400 000
chantiers on a à peu près quel que soit
le niveau de travaux on a à peu près un
quart un quart à 25 % de non conformité
après on a juste pour la précision on a
on a un niveau de conformité que vous si
vous avez eu l'occasion de regarder
l'étude on a un niveau de conformité que
aux alentours de 50% mais on a aussi un
niveau de non vérifiable qui est par
exemple pour des combles quand on ne
peut pas accéder aux comptes parce qu'il
y a pas de trap parce que l'isolation a
été faite par le toit et bah c'est c'est
un chantier Dinant vérifiable donc on
peut pas le compter en en confort donc
pour revenir donc sur les 25% de nos
conformité on a la panoplie de de de
d'un certain nombre de de de de
problèmes donc on a on a on a des des
problèmes de de fraude soit à la à la
quantité donc à la quantité par exemple
d'isolation pour gonfler les primes ces
deux œufs on a des fraudes liés au fait
de de pas avoir fait les travaux d'avoir
fait les travaux dans des zones non
éligibles de typiquement d'avoir isolé
un garage ou d'avoir isolé une grange
qui est pas qui est pas habité etc on a
aussi des non qualités qui sont liées à
à des problèmes de de maîtrise on va
dire de formation une maîtrise du
travail donc vous avez vous avez des
problèmes non qualités qui peuvent qui
peuvent être parfois dangereux
on a aussi on a aussi des problèmes de
de
sur la maîtrise de la de la
documentation liée à au dispositif c'est
à dire que typiquement comme vous avez
pas comme vous avez pas
remis la le cadre de contribution quand
vous avez pas quand vous avez pas
respecté
l'éligibilité sur un certain nombre de
critères etc donc moi je calibrer plus
ça d'une non maîtrise du du
dispositif que d'une fraude ou que d'une
non qualité et puis après
enfin on a on a on a aussi bien sûr des
des des des proches je le dis de de
problèmes de de d'artisan peut
scrupuleux qui qui
font des travaux qui font des travaux
maclés
voilà pour pour
le propos introductif et puis à votre
disposition
c'est à vous merci
j'ai effectivement vous l'avez rappelé
tout à l'heure publié entre janvier et
février et une série d'enquêtes dans le
Moniteur des artisans et sur le
Moniteur.fr et dans le Moniteur
hebdomadaire version rouge
ces enquêtes ont démarré en décembre
lorsque des entreprises à savoir des
industriels des négociants et des
entreprises de travaux des artisans
m'ont alerté ainsi que d'autres sur le
fait que l'ANAH avait cessé de leur
verser ce qu'elle leur devait au titre
de ma prime rénov puisque ces
entreprises étaient mandataires et ses
paiements c'était arrêté depuis
plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs mois
je pense que beaucoup d'élus locaux et
de parlementaires ont été saisis par ces
entreprises locales à ce moment-là
donc j'ai cherché à en savoir un peu
plus on parlait j'ai souvenir de d'ordre
de grandeur d'ailleurs les la situation
n'est pas réglé mais j'ai souvenir
d'ordre de grandeurs d'entreprises
parlant de 2 millions d'euros en attente
pour une quinzaine de millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires donc dans une la
vie d'une entreprise dans une période de
hausse des coûts il s'agissait en
l'occurrence d'un négociant donc il y a
du stock sur les entreprises artisanales
le chiffre d'affaires était plus petit
le mais le ratio était à peu près le
même donc on parlait quand même d'une
sortie d'argent qui les mettait en péril
alors que c'était des gens qui de bonne
foi c'était engagés dans un dispositif
public
je n'ai pas réussi à voir de réponses de
Lana si ce n'est que c'est stop de
paiement était justifié par la lutte
contre la fraude et à partir de là je me
suis demandé quelle fraude pouvait bien
justifier le fait de mettre à ce point
de difficulté des entreprises
que je savais
honnête ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'elle
n'est jamais commis d'erreur dans leur
vie mais en tout cas elle ne méritait
pas un tel traitement
il en est sorti une première enquête en
cinq volets alors je précise que le
moniteur est un journal professionnel je
ne me suis pas intéressé aux fraudes aux
consommateurs dont pas parler les
représentants de la dgcf et dont je
pense par le rond mais mes
interlocuteurs après moi
je me suis vraiment intéressé à ses
professionnels de la fraude
qui parfois porte atteintes aux
consommateur parfois pas soit parce
qu'il y a pas de consommateur parce
qu'on est dans des secteurs non
résidentiels soit parce qu'au fond le
consommateur enfin comme Monsieur j'ai
dit parlait de d'isoler une grange qui
n'est pas éligible il n'y a pas de
fraude au consommateur ça lui pas
peut-être même que ça lui profite c'est
possible
ce premier vol est d'enquête a donc
dégagé une série de mécaniques de fraude
par exhaustive mais qui donnait un
panorama de ce que j'avais pu comprendre
avec une importance majeure des des
leads donc des contacts qualifiés
des gros poids de SAP qui d'escrocs de
la Réno alors évidemment il s'appelle
pas comme ça mais qui sont effectivement
très alerte sur le dispositif public ça
se dire que dans deux mois faudra faire
du poêle à bois mais que d'ici là il
faut faire de la chaudière etc ou qui
échangent leur je veux pas dire bonne
pratique mais leur mauvaise pratique sur
tout un tas de manières de faire
les faux comptes à Lana dont je pense
que vous êtes déjà saisi sur le fait que
via alors ce sont des acteurs qui ont
pour certains d'entre eux déjà vrai dans
le CPF et dans d'autres dispositifs
publics qu'on retrouve dans la
rénovation énergétique qui dispose de
base solide et qui du coup ont les
identifiant France Connect qui sont le
sésame pour aller se porter mandataire
sur le site de la NAS de particuliers
qui ne sont même pas au courant qu'ils
ont déposés une demande de dossier et
puis ensuite l'argent disparaît dans les
circuits que Madame Guy et Monsieur
Roussel décrivaient tout à l'heure
il est apparu aussi dans cette enquête
qu'il y avait un sérieux sujet sur les
produits alors je les concentré parce
que c'est là où j'avais le plus
d'informations à ce moment là sur la
ventilation qui a fait l'objet en 2022
d'une bonification de ma prime rénov
sur la DMC double flux
et il est ressorti que plusieurs acteurs
avaient trouvé les moyens de mettre sur
le marché dans des proportions
importantes puisque certains industriels
ayant pignon sur rue sur la ventilation
m'ont dit que leur part de marché avait
baissé alors que le dispositif était
incroyable ce qui veut donc dire que les
produits installés n'ont pas profité aux
industriels qui éventuellement avaient
investi en France et en Europe pour pour
cela et donc on faisait venir d'Italie
ou d'Espagne ou d'ailleurs des produits
pas du tout conformes et qu'on installé
à toute vitesse c'est que évidemment on
n'était jamais rattrapé puisque
l'imagination des fraudeurs va toujours
plus vite que le les possibilités de les
contrôler
et enfin alors donc je parlais de
ventilation j'ai appris depuis pas mal
de choses notamment sur le solaire
thermique qui subit exactement le même
genre de phénomène avec l'installation
notamment de ces termes aussi font qui
sont ces ballons à la grecque ou à la
méditerranéenne qu'on voit sur les toits
qui sont probablement parfaits dans le
bassin méditerranéen mais quand on met
un ballon d'eau chaude sur un toit en
Auvergne a priori l'eau ne reste pas
chaude
et puis le dernier sujet était consacré
à une fiche C2E qui s'appelle Bart th164
qui est la fiche qui finance la
rénovation globale qui est un sujet en
soi l'UFC Que Choisir d'ailleurs publié
un excellent article à ce sujet en
janvier également
cette fiche en fait
détermine un volume de C2E en fonction
du de l'état initial du bâtiment de la
maison individuelle et de son point
d'arrivée après travaux
le dispositif est les particulièrement
intéressant avant décembre 2021 donc il
y a ce titre trois étages à la fraude le
premier consiste à anti dater les devis
l'état n'ayant arrêté qu'au 31 mars
dernier le dépôt de devis d'avant le
décembre 2021 donc on voit en ce moment
là sur les dernières lettres
d'information des C2E affluer des
volumes remarquables de rénovation
globale dont à vrai dire personne ne
pense qu'elle soit réelle donc à
l'antidatation le deuxième niveau
consiste à
dégrader dans l'évaluation thermique
dégradée l'état initial de la maison
ce qui fait qu'il n'y aura pas besoin de
faire grand chose pour
générer un maximum de ces deux œufs on
m'a ainsi montré des études thermiques
avec La Rochelle à 1900 mètres
d'altitude ce qui évidemment crée un
vrai différentiel thermique ou des
communes qui étaient en grand nombre
artificiellement situés dans le
département du Doubs qui se trouve être
le plus froid de France
et autres
inventivité remarquable et enfin il y a
une petite route technique sur la PAC et
pas petite c'est que la pompe à chaleur
est toujours considérée installé en
basse température avec fonctionnant à 35
degrés alors qu'en vrai elle
fonctionnera à 60 et qu'évidemment sa
performance n'est pas la même donc ça
c'est le premier volet
et j'ai consacré une deuxième série en
février expressément au bureau de
contrôle C2E
[Musique]
monsieur j'ai dit en parler tout à
l'heure ils sont 51 à crédités par le
coffrac alors je précise qu'il y a une
grande majorité de ces 51 qui sont des
gens honnêtes et qui font très bien leur
travail donc je ne jette pas l'eau
propre sur une profession
je me suis livré un travail de
d'identification de ces structures de
leur dirigeants et de leurs liens
d'intérêt
en précisant que d'ailleurs ces liens à
mon avis n'était pas spécialement légaux
mais il semblait pas non plus
nécessairement illégaux enfin il y avait
un vrai flou réglementaire qui était pas
c'était pas clairement
identifié pour moi
j'ai donc trouvé 27 % d'entre eux qui
présentaient des liens soit avec les
entreprises de travaux soit avec le
monde des C2E
sur 51 ça fait beaucoup enfin ça fait
beaucoup en soi mais bon ça veut dire
qu'il y en a une quinzaine
ce qui signifie qu'on assiste
effectivement à ce que décrivait
monsieur Jedi c'est à dire un système
qui peut impliquer un énergéticien un
délégataire C2E des entreprises de
travaux un bureau de contrôle un
évaluateur thermique tout ça fonctionne
en vase clos
notamment pour la fiche barth-164 dont
je vous parlais précédemment c'est très
utile c'est à dire qu'une fois qu'on
détient tout ça bah on peut produire du
certificat d'économie d'énergie à tour
de bras
cette cette fiche là elle est
sympathique c'est les contrôler à 100%
donc
elle est contrôlée sans être contrôlé à
100% par un bureau de contrôle et ce qui
n'a pas empêché allègrement la fraude
et le coffrac fait mention dans les
critères de d'accréditation de ces
bureaux de contrôle de la compétence
technique requise
je me suis alors c'est très difficile
d'évaluer la compétence technique d'un
bureau de contrôle mais j'ai notamment
souvenir d'un
d'entre eux qui a le même gérant qu'un
magasin de scooter dans Paris même
adresse et sans plaque sur le bâtiment
et le profil du gérant ne laisse pas
supposer qu'il en sachent plus que moi
sur les travaux et même probablement
nettement moins donc
voilà j'ai soulevé ça avec la précaution
qui convient
[Musique]
en conclusion
je suis ressorti de cette enquête alors
que pas terminée je livre à sans doute
d'autres volets
avec un sentiment partagé c'est à dire
que j'ai eu le sentiment que côté Anna
je crois pas du tout à la
pertinence de leur réponse mais j'ai
l'impression qu'ils sont quand même
qu'ils essayent d'apporter une réponse
notamment via l'arrêt de ses paiements
le temps d'effectuer des contrôles
arrête à mon avis reste très
problématique mais enfin en tout cas ils
essayent d'apporter une réponse
côté ces deux œufs j'ai pas forcément eu
ce sentiment j'ai écrit un article en
mars pour décrire les volumes qui
arrivaient de Bart et h164 dont on
pensait qu'ils étaient frauduleux à date
et à ma connaissance vous me contredirez
peut-être mais le pnc2e n'a toujours pas
ordonné de contrôle systématique a
posteriori de ses volumes que toute la
filière c'est être à 90 ou 95%
frauduleux
donc je n'ai pas senti qu'il y avait
côté
ces deux œufs la même
envie peut-être que côté Anna de
s'attaquer aux problèmes
et puis j'ai aussi été assez surpris de
alors peut-être que la dgcf me
contredira mais il était demandé je
crois dans la loi de 2019 qu'il y a un
fichier centralisé des chantiers et des
en France et je crois que ce fichier
n'existe pas
les organismes de qualification
notamment qualibates et sont extrêmement
conscients du problème et ne sont pas
associés par l'administration à la
mission à l'ami CAF dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure madame sur
les cellules de lutte antifraud du
ministère de l'économie qui me répond
que non parce que c'est une cellule
administrative et cannibale quand on
attaque sa décision on attaque au
tribunal administratif donc c'est ok
c'est une structure privée mais c'est
une structure avec une mission de
service public et que
l'État restait encore et j'ai très bien
entendu ce que dit l'ADV donc je sais
qu'elle travaille très bien mais l'État
dans son ensemble reste encore
loin d'être en mesure de de doubler
quelques les fraudeurs dans leur
inventivité
et effectivement il y a des inquiétudes
que Monsieur j'ai dit évocation mon
accompagnateur rénov et il y en a aussi
pas mal sur ma prime adapte qui sort du
champ de la rénovation énergétique mais
qui arrive sur le champ de
l'accessibilité l'année prochaine et qui
promet je crois si rien de en tout cas
si le dispositif est effectivement
calqué sur ma prime rénov
qui promet quelques désagréments majeurs
et pour le coup qui seront
essentiellement liés à la à la
consommation j'en ai fini pour l'instant
j'ai oublié votre nom je suis désolé
Rodrigue
merci madame la Présidente je veux pas
revenir sur les propos concernant
protection du consommateur puisque la
DGCCRF est déjà terminé longuement
dessus je voulais juste faire petits
éléments de cadrage notamment sur ses
propres introductifs sur les litiges
liés à la rénovation énergétique déjà
qui faut globaliser un peu l'ensemble et
voir dans quel domaine nous nous
trouvons nous nous trouvons sur des
problématiques de travaux et de manière
générale
les travaux donnent façon très
importante lieux à des litiges quel
qu'il soit c'est pas spécifique à
l'innovation énergétique c'est dès lors
que vous avez un professionnel un
artisan qui vient vous avez très
régulièrement des malfaçons ou
différents problèmes qui donnent lieu à
satisfaction il y a plein de
consommateurs que ce soit sur des
retards de chantier que ce soit sur des
abandons purement et simplement de
chantier ou que ce soit lorsque dans le
meilleur des cas les travaux sont
réalisés que donne lieu a des malfaçons
donc c'est vrai que c'est générique à
cette problématique et donc il n'est pas
surprenant malheureusement que les
travaux d'économie d'énergie a également
le même type de litige à savoir la
mauvaise réalisation des travaux ou
encore des performances des économies
d'énergie qui étaient escomptés qui
étaient attendus qui finalement ne le
sont pas donc c'est vrai que tout cela
peut également peut également
s'interroger est-ce qu'on est la plupart
du temps sur des contrats d'adhésion on
est sur parfois des simples devis qui
sont signés tout juste daté sans avoir
des des informations nécessaires sur la
durée du chantier sur le point de départ
ou la date d'achèvement du chantier
alors même qu'on a des textes
effectivement qui disent que ces
informations doivent être communiquées
gérer de manière générale ce qui aurait
pas nécessité de cadrer un petit peu
tout cela avec un contrat type par
exemple qui serait clairement formalisé
et notamment parce que là on est sur les
travaux d'économie d'énergie avec
l'obligation pour le professionnel de
renseigner toutes les informations
utiles qui permettraient au
consommateurs cas échéant de procéder au
contrôle pertinent qui suivent
ensuite sur les litiges même à notre
sens sont quand même aussi grandement
favorisés
pas très grande complexité des
différentes aides existantes et je défie
toute personne j'ai acquis n'est pas
initié de pouvoir expliquer bien
évidemment toutes les études qui
existent ouais même les initiés de toute
façon entre effectivement les aides de
Lana entre les deux œufs entre les aides
locales lorsque vous avez une
municipalité une agglomération qui va
sur abonder ou lorsque c'est l'ANA qui
sera bon lorsque vous avez une aide au
niveau local les éventuels crédits
d'impôts c'est absolument impossible
pour le consommateur moyen ou pas même
pour le consommateur averti de se
retrouver tout là-dedans et il est
facile pour un professionnel qui est un
minimum de bagou et ce sont
malheureusement les plus redoutables du
bien écoutez ça ne vous coûtera rien ou
à part avec les fameux travaux 1 € la
problématique c'est est-ce que j'avance
les trois quatre cinq mille euros je
remboursé après ou non vous avancez il y
a pas de souci vous sauver un chèque
après le chèque n'arrive jamais voilà
donc c'est vrai on a réel maki sur ces
éléments là et malgré les efforts de
communication des pouvoirs publics des
efforts de Lana les efforts de l'ADEME
n'y arrivent pas donc très clairement il
faudra à nouveau relancer davantage de
communication et peut-être également
simplifier c'est clair qu'on est censé y
avoir un guichet unique de la rénovation
énergétique je pense qu'il est pas connu
ou très peu connu et il faut vraiment
sensibiliser consommateurs sur ce point
on parlait où on va en parler tout à
l'heure de du démarchage à domicile là
encore mon conseil régulièrement c'est
attendez avant de vous engager alors
même qui est censé être interdit
n'oubliez pas que c'est le professionnel
qui a besoin de VOUS pas vous qui avez
besoin du professionnel parce que vous
n'êtes pas à l'origine de la demande
mais n'hésitez pas à faire des contrôles
à posteriori sur ces qualifications
ensuite précisément nous en tant que
consommateur donc la plupart de nos
actions sont quand même centrées sur la
sensibilisation de du particulier du
consommateur également des
copropriétaires mais que ce soit pas
syndicat n'est pas un consommateur donc
systématiquement on les renvoie sur les
organismes existants donc enfin sur Lana
sur France renomme on sensibilise
également sur existence du label RGE
pour autant dire qu'il est pas forcément
bien compris par le consommateur qui va
faire la malgame avec d'autres types de
labels on va dire à connotation
davantage commercial se posant plus
l'application de ce label RGE si je
passe par une entreprise qui labellisée
mais que celle-ci sous-traite à une
entreprise qui n'est pas dépositaire du
label RGE est-ce que finalement en tant
consommateur je suis couvert je vais
bénéficier des aides financières ou non
donc là aussi c'est pas forcément
toujours clair donc on essaie de
sensibiliser si au maximum sur ces
questions là mais de façon ça ça reste
malheureusement assez assez suffisant
donc
juste un lien vous vous posiez la
relation ou la corrélation entre lutte
contre la fraude et massifications des
travaux d'économie d'énergie bon est-ce
qu'il faut lutter contre la fraude bien
évidemment oui quel que soit l'incidence
de cette lutte sur la massification
est-ce qu'elle aura un impact à mon sens
oui est-ce qu'elle aura un impact très
important la question se pose pourquoi
parce que déjà généralement cette fraude
on les trouve surtout les individuels
c'est plus rare dans dans le collectif
en copropriété vous pouvez avoir
d'autres problématiques peut-être qu'il
y a mal façon mais plus rarement à des
contredire mais moi de ce que j'ai
effectivement comme témoignage oui alors
pas voir sur du calorifugeage alors là
c'était peut-être un abus du des travaux
1 € les entreprises sont arrivées ils
ont tout fait un euro ils ont fait du
calorificage à 1 euro ils ont fait du de
l'isolation des plafonds des plans des
plats des plonges des plats en bas à 1 €
notamment tout ce qui concerne les caves
avons été effectués après ce qu'ils ont
été bien réalisé mal réalisés ce qui est
un contrôle derrière effectivement si on
se pose c'est vrai ça a poussé dedans
mais sur des gros opérations
d'innovation énergétique c'est surtout
ça également qui importe là je pense
et je voyais qu'effectivement le Leclerc
a priori il semblait être sur la même
position qu'on a moins de problématiques
sur ces sujets là
le consommateur va réaliser les travaux
d'économie d'énergie généralement
pourquoi parce que d'une part on a une
contrainte liée à la décence donc là je
vois notamment la situation du coup
propriétaire Bayer donc les travaux il
va être obligés de les réaliser sinon le
logement ne pourrait pas être ne
pourrait plus jouer on a également la
problématique du confort bien évidemment
et c'est la première chose lorsqu'on
parle de rénovation énergétique auprès
de nos adhérents c'est de penser pas
forcément entendre retour mais pensez
également en amélioration du confort et
puis après il y a bien évidemment et là
avec la hausse de l'énergie il y a la
question li au pouvoir d'achat donc la
réalisation des travaux d'économie
d'énergie est quand même sentie comme
une nécessité plus ou moins importante
selon les caractéristiques et la
situation du consommateur mais quand
même comme une nécessité donc la crainte
de la fraude n'est pas forcément un
frein pour lui
la problématique c'est il faut le
protéger pour précisément bien
évidemment quand on doit protéger tout
nos concitoyens il faut le protéger des
mauvais professionnels et voir qu'est-ce
que l'on met en place pour améliorer ses
contrôles donc pour voir on a des
sanctions on a effectivement un problème
de blocs on a eu l'allament là quand
même du démarchage téléphonique donc
avoir comment est-ce que les
professionnels qui font du démarchage
mais sur les travaux d'économies
d'énergie donc on va voir ce que ils
sont concernés d'ailleurs par cette
exception non
vont ça voilà s'introduire dans cette
dérogation avec toutes les conséquences
malheureusement qui peuvent en découler
donc je pense qu'il faut
avancer quelques quelques correctifs
juridiques malheureusement les
professionnels c'est vrai enfin les les
bigalots on va dire comme cela auront
toujours un temps d'avance sur nous dans
le sens où elle vont être mise à l'aise
seront à l'étranger domicile à
l'étranger donc il y aura peu de moins
d'action mais qu'on puisse à minima
anticiper la problématique avec des
contrats normés avec des clauses
obligatoires avec éventuellement des
pénalités de retard qui pourraient être
imposées automatiquement comme on le
trouve notamment dans le cadre de
contrat de consommation individuels vous
avez des opérations travaux d'économie
d'énergie qui servent sont pas le prix
d'une maison mais qui peuvent être
extrêmement coûteux extrêmement
coûteuses de milliers d'euros donc
notion de pénalité de retard pour
également avoir un intérêt et puis là
encore c'est
sensibiliser à notre sens sur le réel
intérêt du label RGE
qui invention ce n'est pas très bien
perçu et compris par le consommateur
merci beaucoup alors il nous reste à
entendre Monsieur debier et Madame
buisson
merci madame la Présidente donc on a
regardé un petit peu les auditions que
vous avez déjà faites donc on va éviter
de répéter les choses avec lesquelles on
est d'accord donc on est d'accord bon
sur les grandes lignes sur toutes les
observations que l'on vient d'entendre
et puis on est d'accord aussi sur le
fait que l'intérêt du consommateur de
base de la rénovation on ne voit que des
avantages pour le consommateur avantage
sur la réduction de la facture avantage
sur le confort divers confort d'été sur
l'autonomie moins de risques sur les
crises des prix des énergies etc on ne
voit que des avantages pour le
consommateur mais il y a aussi on ne
voit que des avantages pour la
collectivité pour l'État puisque s'il y
a moins de consommation c'est aussi
moins de dépendance de l'État aux
fournisseurs d'énergie à l'étranger donc
on se pose la question
donc ça va être la difficulté pour ceux
qui vont inventer les prochaines mesures
de trouver un dispositif enfin efficace
puisque moi en ce qui me concerne je
suis les problèmes d'énergie depuis un
demi siècle et depuis un demi siècle je
suis étonné que malgré tous les
avantages que l'on que tout le monde
reconnaît à la aux économies d'énergie à
la rénovation des logements et bien
aujourd'hui
quand on a la crise très grave de
l'hiver dernier et bien les tout le
monde est en difficulté les
consommateurs les citoyens et l'État
voilà donc
on n'a pas de solution miracle à
proposer mais on a quelques propositions
malgré tout
donc ma collègue parlera des sources de
fraude puisque c'était une de vos
questions
en ce qui concerne donc les propositions
ce que l'on demande nous depuis très
longtemps c'est que le consommateur
puisse avoir une source d'information
fiable et indépendante donc tout le
monde l'a souligné c'est le cas de
autrefois des points énergiques ont
changé de nom trois quatre fois c'est un
peu dommage que ça change de nom
régulièrement et puis ensuite on fait le
constat tout le monde peut le faire si
on interroge 10 personnes autour de soi
un site des 10 citoyens moyens qui n'ont
pas de source d'informations
particulières ils sont confrontés aux
démarchage donc qui existe toujours des
marcheurs téléphoniques qui existent
toujours à la publicité
omniprésente sur tous les médias et puis
par contre donc la seule source
d'information fiable France rénove et
bien il y a très peu de gens qui
connaissent donc à partir du moment où
les gens ne connaissent pas au point de
départ la bonne source de conseil
forcément il y a de fortes chances qu'il
tombe dans le panneau dès que quelqu'un
veut profiter de la situation comme il a
été dit tout à l'heure
sur ce qui avait été dit également donc
bon on va passer s'étendre là-dessus
donc priorité une source d'information
connue qui devrait être connu de tout le
monde indépendantes complètes qui a les
moyens on a remarqué ces derniers mois
que au lieu d'avoir des informations
plus disponibles on a plutôt tendance à
voir les les organismes qui sont
débordés parce qu'il y a plus de
demandes et ils ont pas plus de moyens
et ensuite donc les associations la
table ronde de vous avez eu les
associations ont noté également le
besoin d'accompagnement c'est-à-dire il
faut au départ les bons conseils et
ensuite de préférence un accompagnement
qui soit indépendant des artisans des
entreprises
voilà bon on n'est pas on est conscient
également comme l'a dit la DGCCRF
qu'il y a un déséquilibre entre l'offre
et la demande donc on va vers une
période où il y a de plus en plus de
demandes des consommateurs et on sait
très bien que du côté des artisans ils
n'ont pas eu la mise à jour des
connaissances et les formations qui le
permettent qui permettent de répondre à
la demande on l'a vu également aussi
pour le DPE
puisqu'on a fait une enquête donc ma
collègue Lucille vous en parlera où on
voit très nettement que les résultats
sont tout à fait en déficit par rapport
à ce que l'on peut attendre
je vous remercie
alors madame buisson pour terminer
oui merci madame la Présidente donc en
effet considérant vos questions enfin le
questionnaire envoyé et
l'orientation donc cette audition autour
des litiges c'est vrai que pour l'UFC
Que Choisir le secteur de la rénovation
énergétique est particulièrement
pourvoyeur de litige environ 10 000 par
an ils peuvent ça peut aller du
démarchage à la malfaçon à l'abandon de
chantier ça a été cité ou à la
nonantation nonobtention pardon de
d'aide promise par les professionnels
c'est litige il se polarise autour de
pratique de commercialisation et
d'équipements particuliers s'agissant
des pratiques de commercialisation
d'abord les contrats souscrits en foire
et salon sans problématique puisque un
droit particulier s'applique à ces
contrats
sans qui n'ont pas de délai de
rétractation et
c'est donc au-delà de ce droit des
pratiques frauduleuses sont également
observés au sein des foirés salons à
travers notamment de des affichages
frauduleux de RGE de la belle RGE mais
ce qui représente deux tiers à peu près
des litiges enfin des réclamations que
nous recevons sont liés à du démarchage
physique donc nous avons accueilli
l'interdiction du démarchage
téléphonique comme un premier pas
salutaire
mais il se trouve que le démarchage
physique
reste un fléau et que et que à notre
sens il serait nécessaire de d'aller
vers une interdiction sectorielle de ce
démarchage
donc ça c'est pour s'agissant des
pratiques de commercialisation sur les
équipements on remarque des litiges
particulièrement sur les pompes à
chaleur et sur l'isolation et ça on le
relie à des campagnes qui partent bien
évidemment d'une bonne intention des
campagnes dédiées à ces gestes en
particulier et qui crée des effets
d'aubaine des appels d'air qui ont été
largement renseignés pour des
entreprises peu scrupule peu
scrupuleuses et donc là on a on remarque
particulièrement des malfaçons et des
non achèvement
au-delà donc on pense que c'est que ces
arnaques c'est fraudes elles ont
contribué à un développement d'une
défiance des consommateurs vis-à-vis de
ce secteur mais au-delà de ça la
rénovation énergétique c'est un
investissement important pour le
consommateur l'élémentants sont
importants et en face les gains
d'énergie ne sont pas toujours garanties
pour revenir sur le parcours d'un
consommateur lambda qui désire exécuter
faire exécuter des travaux de rénovation
énergétique tout d'abord se pose la
question de la définition des travaux à
réaliser donc là nos attentes sur le
dispositif accompagnateur et rénov sont
importantes et
s'agissant aussi du travail de France
Renov qui sont pour nous qui viennent
pour nous un accompagnement à la fois
administratif les différentes
temporalités des aides et la difficulté
de lecture des différentes aides a été
rappelée et aussi technique et à notre
sens
considérant donc les objectifs des
pouvoirs publics en matière de
rénovation énergétique et les attentes
des consommateurs
l'accompagnement doit ce systématiser et
doit se baser sur
un premier un premier bilan proposant
différents scénarios de rénovation
globale ici nous faisons référence aux
différentes enquêtes trémies qui ont mis
en avant que la majorité des gains
énergétiques obtenus en matière de
rénovation sans réalité liée à des
rénovations globales elles ont un
intérêt donc pour les pouvoirs publics
en matière d'atteinte d'objectifs de
réduction de la consommation énergétique
par là de l'émission de gaz à effet de
serre et naturellement pour le
consommateur puisque ces rénovations
sont plus efficaces et donc permettent
une
baisse de la consommation énergétique et
donc des factures donc au-delà de donc
c'est ce que je décris ici ce sont les
prérequis à notre sens en matière
d'accompagnement mais s'agissant des
travaux réalisés pour nous il est
essentiel que il y a un engagement
s'agissant des économies d'énergie qui
peut se baser sur le DPE un despe avant
et après et qui permet d'attester de la
validité des travaux éventuellement aux
consommateurs si besoin est de
faire valoir ses promesses
contractualiser auprès du professionnel
dans le cas de malfaçons par exemple
voilà c'est tout pour moi merci beaucoup
monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci Madame merci madame la
Présidente merci d'abord à l'ensemble de
vos interventions très très précis c'est
vrai que c'est pour le coup un sujet un
sujet complexe en tout cas on voit bien
toutes les problématiques au-delà de la
politique de rénovation après sur
l'application sur le sur le terrain et
puis du coup toutes les et oui les
fraudes et les dérives qui peuvent se
produire moi j'avais plusieurs plusieurs
questions alors après vous répondrai en
fonction enfin mais notamment d'abord
peut-être sur la DGCCRF mais
notamment sur le
vous avez plutôt décrit globalement mais
la DGCCRF plutôt sur le fait qu'il y
avait beaucoup de fraude et en tout cas
beaucoup de fraude qui était qui était
vous pouvez voir sur le sur le terrain
et lié à la rénovation thermique c'est
vrai que quand on a auditionné la
ministre il y a quelques temps elle
était très modérée sur cet aspect là en
disant oui il y a des fraudes mais quand
on regarde par rapport à au nombre de
prime rénov et de dossiers qui sont
faits en fait on est sur sur des un
nombre de fraudes qui est limité donc
c'est ce qu'elle nous disait donc du
coup je voulais avoir votre votre avis
par rapport à ça en tout cas si comment
vous vous analysez chaud et quand vous
entendez l’impression quand même de
l'inverse quoi en tout cas que c'était
quelque chose d'assez massif et d'assez
important
donc je vais avoir cette étape cet
aspect là et puis c'est vrai qu'aussi on
vous entendant sur le fait que on voit
bien que le contrôle et le contrôle sur
sur place ou en tout cas à la fois
sur des fraudes mais aussi sur des
réalisations de travaux pour vérifier
qu'ils sont correctement fait mais sur
le travail de la DGCCRF est-ce que du
coup vous estimez que vous avez un
effectif dédié suffisant et en tout cas
par rapport à ce que vous réalisez
actuellement comme contrôle et comme
contrôle sur les fraudes est-ce que
c'est enfin voilà vous estimez ça en
tout cas suffisant ou est-ce qu'il
faudrait multiplier doubler tripler j'en
sais rien le nombre d'interventions sur
sur ces sur ces fraudes
donc voilà si vous pouvez nous répondre
par rapport à ça ensuite peut-être plus
globalement sur sur l'ensemble c'est
savoir si vous aviez des des exemples en
fait de dispositifs d'autres pays
qui pourraient du coup en tout cas quand
peut-être trouver jamais la parade au
fraude mais en tout cas sur des
dispositifs qui qui en tout cas génèrent
moins de fraudes en tout cas qui qui
permettent de contrôler plus facilement
en tout cas le système je pense
notamment je crois que c'est l'Allemagne
qui fonctionne un petit peu comme ça
c'est vrai qu'on a un peu une habitude
en France où on a mis un label RGE sur
les entreprises en se disant en gros on
a une entreprise qui est labellisée donc
on estime que les travaux qu'elle
réalisent sont correctes et voilà et en
fait on a très peu de contrôle voire pas
du tout en fin de en fin de chantier et
donc en fait la prime est versée
quel que soit en fait la qualité des la
qualité des travaux c'est vrai que je
crois que en Allemagne en fait peu
importe
c'est vraiment le
bilan qui est fait des travaux et savoir
s'ils répondent en fait aux exigences
qui ont été annoncées et puis ensuite la
prime et la prime est RC donc je voulais
savoir en tout cas si vous aviez des des
retours ou des ou des reculs sur cette
sur cet aspect là peut-être aussi sur
j'avais pu voir ça sur le fait que c'est
vrai qu'on verse la prime les aides aux
particuliers à la personne qui fait les
travaux c'est vrai qu'on pourrait
imaginer aussi d'avoir plutôt des aides
qui soient versées à l'entreprise avec
toutes les problématiques comment
mais pas forcément enfin je veux dire là
là on a on a plein de cas de personnes
qui font leurs travaux parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les ensembles des documents
qui ne vont pas toucher leur prime et
ensuite du coup qu'il la touche quand
jamais parce que ils ont pas eu soit les
travaux n'ont pas été achevés soit
ils ont pas eu le bon document enfin en
tout cas le devis de faire le plutôt la
facture terminée donc la facture elle
est pas enfin la prime elle est bien
versée à celui qui commande les travaux
elle est pas versée à l'entreprise
pour avoir utilisé ma prime rénov je
pense que enfin c'est la prime rénov
elle est elle est bien inversée aux
commanditaire quoi elle est pas versée à
l'entreprise
là-dessus et puis après je voulais
savoir si vous aviez eu connaissance en
fait sur la question des fichiers et
notamment sur tout ce qu'on peut trouver
sur internet pour aller l'avoir fait
récemment d'avoir rentré un dossier on
va les refaire fait semblant de rentrer
un dossier sur une isolation de de
maison
et qu'on va sur le site France Renov
voilà
comme il faut on va dire entre elle et
une demi-heure après on reçoit un
certain nombre de d'appels et donc ça
veut bien dire que les données qui sont
rentrées dans ce fichier sont transmis
et ensuite j'ai reçu notamment beaucoup
d'appels sur changer une pompe à chaleur
alors que j'avais moins rentré tout ce
qu'il fallait sur l'isolation de ma
maison et je voulais savoir si vous
aviez des cas en tout cas comme ça et
est-ce que de quelle manière on peut en
tout cas éviter cette cette
problématique cette problématique là et
puis en allant dans ce sens là aussi je
regardais là je le faisais tout à
l'heure quand on tape par exemple ma
prime rénove
2023 le premier site sur lequel je tombe
par exemple c'est un site avec le logo
du gouvernement pompe à chaleur etc et
en fait c'est tout simplement un vendeur
de pompe à chaleur qui va faire son et
donc ça c'est vrai que c'est si on fait
le parcours classique de quelqu'un qui
dit tiens je vais je vais faire mes je
vais faire mes travaux on tombe sur un
certain nombre de choses comme ça qui du
coup
désoriente désoriente totalement donc je
pense que c'est aussi un aspect donc
savoir si son niveau de la DGCCRF si
vous aviez des éléments aussi par
rapport à ça et puis peut-être un petit
point aussi sur la loi du 24 juillet
2020 là sur le nom des marges parce que
j'ai pas l'impression on a marché
téléphonique
savoir si l'impact en fait de ce texte
là fin de cette de cette loi parce que
oui elle existe du coup il y a des des
PV qui sont qui sont dressés etc mais
est-ce que ça a réellement fait diminuer
ce démarchage se démarchage téléphonique
et puis par rapport à ce qui était dit
du coup sur le démarchage physique qui
est aussi compliqué à mettre en place
mais voilà c'est déjà peut-être
intéressant d'avoir un petit bilan déjà
de de ce texte qui interdit le
démarchage téléphonique merci
alors qu'il souhaite commencer à
apporter des réponses
à des gestes
quelques quelques éléments
donc en lien avec votre question par
rapport au fraude à l'ampleur de la
fraude et offre de ma prime rénove et
l'efficacité de
la politique de contrôle en général
alors c'est vrai que ma prime rénove
c'est quand même un mon accompagnateur
rénove plus encore ce sont des
dispositifs quand même assez récents
donc c'est vrai qu'on a pas forcément le
recul suffisant par rapport à nos
enquêtes pour arriver au niveau de la
DGCCRF adresser un bilan global d'autant
que très souvent en fait parce qu'on
constate dans nos enquêtes c'est qu'on a
quand même un certain nombre d'anomalies
qui sont assez transversales à
différents dispositifs donc on n'a pas
forcément non plus le système
statistique suffisamment fin pour
arriver à quantifier en fait les
différents types de fraudes
compartiments par compartiment ou type
de gestes par type de gestes isolation
pas de photovoltaïques et compagnie
néanmoins on a quand même un certain
nombre d'éléments qui permettent de
c'est la fraude sur le type de
manquement et d'anomalie qu'on a pu
détecter en particulier on s'attache à
établir un chiffrage de l'Indus qui est
généré par la fraude à la rénovation
énergétique via les informations donc
ils sont générés dans nos enquêtes
annuelles avec un certain nombre de
limite un méthodologie
nous avons pu estimer sur l'année 2020
que le montant de l'Indus lié aux
pratiques litigieuses décelées par nos
contrôles étaient estimés à environ 22
millions d'euros il y a plus de 92
millions d'euros sur l'année 2021
sachant que il faut pas interpréter ça
comme une multiplication par 4 un des
fraudes entre 2020 et 2021 ça traduit
aussi le phénomène de monter en charge
de nos contrôles dont on vous parlait
tout à l'heure
et ces montants doivent aussi être
interprétés comme les minorant de la
fraude globale parce qu'en fait on peut
pas faire d'inférence statistiques entre
ce qu'on détecte à travers nos contrôles
et le marché global compte tenu du fait
que on vous expliquait tout à l'heure
qu'il y avait un ciblage fait par nos
enquêteurs sur les les professionnels
qui posaient le plus de problème à
travers des signalements qui nous sont
faits à travers aussi effectivement les
pratiques les plus problématiques qui
sont traitées en priorité donc il faut
prendre quand même ces chiffres avec une
certaine prudence puisque d'une part on
se fondent uniquement donc sur une
fraction des pratiques litigieuses qui
sont mises en avant lors de l'enquête et
d'autre part on peut pas faire
d'extrapolation générale à l'ensemble du
marché mais néanmoins ça permet quand
même d'avoir une première idée un
premier ordre de grandeur de
l'estimation globale
après s'agissant des effectifs qui sont
qui sont déployés sur le terrain comme
on vous le dis expliquait tout à l'heure
on a quasiment doublé le nombre de
contrôles entre 2017 et 2021 et ce
mouvement en fait se poursuit l'année en
année puisque on disait qu'on passait
d'environ 400 établissements contrôlés
en 2017 un objectif de de 1200 en 2023
en 2023
donc c'est pas uniquement en fait une
question de moyens c'est aussi
effectivement la possibilité
d'accompagner
à travers la formation à travers les
actions de sensibilisation à travers les
actions de de formation aux nouvelles
techniques d'enquête et aux nouvelles
types de fraudes les enquêteurs sur le
terrain donc c'est aussi un point qui
faut avoir en tête sachant
qu'effectivement ça reste quand même
parmi nos priorités de développement
stratégique c'est aussi un point un
point important
par rapport au sujet du de la facilité
ou difficulté de contrôle du système
c'est vrai qu'effectivement
un système qui permettrait de sécuriser
davantage en amont
le versement des aides publiques serait
sans doute moins attractif pour un
certain nombre de fraudeurs et
permettrait sans doute de résorber en
amont et de limiter l'ampleur de la
fraude telle qu'on peut la constater sur
le terrain et c'est pour ça
qu'effectivement
à travers des campagnes devient
sensibilisation et qu'on a pu développer
déjà par le passé et qu'on souhaite
aussi reproduire de nouveaux en lien
avec les services notamment du ministère
de la transition écologique en lien avec
l'ADEME et Lana il est important
d'arriver à faire mieux connaître le
dispositif France rénove qui
effectivement est encore insuffisamment
connu aujourd'hui et permettrait nous
semble-t-il s'il était davantage connu
du grand public d'orienter
mieux les consommateurs vers ce tiers de
confiance indépendant et permettrait
sans doute aussi d'être un facteur de
limitation de la fraude
enfin s'agissant effectivement de
l'impact de la loi du 24 juillet 2020
comme je vous l'expliquais effectivement
il y a un certain nombre de
détournements et de contournement qui
sont qui sont qui sont le fait des
professionnels qui font qu'effectivement
l'afro la suite sans doute pas
suffisamment ou en tout cas pas autant
qu'on diminuer qu'on aurait pu l'espérer
à travers ce phénomène de démarchage qui
continue via d'autres canaux aussi
puisque savoir que le démarchage
téléphonique est interdit mais pas le
démarchage par SMS pas le porte-à-porte
donc effectivement un certain nombre de
voix détournées qui font que des
professionnels peuvent scrupuleux
souvent continuent d'arriver à
des marchés et atteindre les publics
parfois fragiles et à leur vendre des
travaux de rénovation énergétique qui
sont pas forcément utiles pour eux et
qui n'ont pas forcément les gestes et
les plus efficients pour également faire
des des sauts de classe énergétiques qui
seraient les plus utiles pour eux
donc ça c'est quelque chose auquel
effectivement on est sensible et à
laquelle effectivement une solution à
laquelle
qui pourrait appeler de nouvelles
évolutions
réglementaires ou législatives si
effectivement on arrivait à bien cerner
effectivement ces difficultés et à
cerner ce péromètre ce périmètre
en termes d'anomalies effectivement sur
les différentes années
l'anomalie liée aux démarches
téléphoniques
sur les différents contrôles on a pu
constater effectivement que les
anomalies persistaient quand même et
dans 41% des cas une
irrégularité était décelée toujours en
matière de démarchage téléphonique donc
c'est vrai que ça continue d'être un
irritant du quotidien pour les
consommateurs et c'est pour ça aussi que
quand les incite très fortement à faire
des signalements dont signal conso
lorsqu'ils sont des marchés de nouveau
par des professionnels de la rénovation
énergétique pour nous aider aussi à
pouvoir enclencher des mesures de
contrôle et de ciblage plus en amont
voilà je sais pas mais si tu souhaites
compléter éventuellement par certains
points alors qui veut prendre la suite
sur la
vente ou la session de fichiers en tout
cas enfin vous avez eu des
informations enfin sur des par rapport
notamment quand on remplit un dossier
prime rénov notamment est-ce que vous
avez déjà constaté en tout cas cette
cette problématique là
alors c'est c'est pas une partie enfin
c'est pas une difficulté particulière
qu'on a pu identifier dans le cas de nos
enquêtes ce qu'on a pu relever de
manière plus générale c'est la collecte
de données donc de ce qu'on appelle le
leads
par le biais notamment d'autres sites
qui peuvent avoir en fait un autre objet
il n'est pas rare qu'il y ait des
opérateurs qui vont effectivement
demander à des consommateurs pour des
services d'une autre nature
leurs coordonnées téléphoniques sans
bien entendu les informer
de la manière dont c'est donner ensuite
seront utilisés et il s'avère
qu'effectivement on a des cas où des
consommateurs ont pu être
sollicités pour les travaux de la
version énergétiques
parce que
leurs coordonnées qu'ils avaient laissé
sur d'autres sites avaient été
réutilisés c'est pour ça qu'on est
particulièrement vigilant notamment dans
le cas de l'interdiction du démarchage
téléphonique
ou à tout l'argumentaire en fait qui est
développé par les professionnels pour
recueillir les coordonnées téléphoniques
et il est important que l'appel soit en
lien direct avec le la prestation de
services pour laquelle les coordonnées
ont été recueillies
qui souhaitent oui monsieur Pichard
j'ai oublié de vous mentionner tout là
mais ça répond à une partie de ce que
vous disiez que une partie de mon
enquête avait aussi porté sur le
maintien des offres 0 et 1 € que le
gouvernement avait annoncé vouloir
terminer suite
Pâques à 0 et isolation à zéro en euros
il y avait une nombreuses que les
associations consommateurs notamment
relevés et le gouvernement a dit il y
aura maintenant un reste à charge de 10%
minimum pour éviter pour que ça coûtera
toujours quelque chose au consommateur
mais on veut éviter ça
tapez pompe à chaleur à 1 € sur Internet
et vous verrez que cette volonté ne
s'est pas éteinte avec alors j'ai
identifié deux montages mais il y en a
sans doute d'autres il y a par exemple
la
contrepartie c'est à dire qu'on fait
chuter le chantier à zéro parce que sur
le 1000 euros restant on va proposer aux
particuliers d'héberger pendant un an
une pub de l'entreprise sur sa façade
et du coup ça c'est chiffré 1000 euros
et donc à la fin le devis à 1-0 et il y
a aussi une fondation
je crois qu'elle est reconnue d'utilité
publique qui recueille des dons
d'installateurs par exemple et qui a un
très beau discours sur la lutte contre
la précarité énergétique et qui sert en
fait à financer le reste à charge donc
il reste des mécanismes de de fraude
assez de fraude cela dit dans ce cas là
on est même pas sûr que ce soit
frauduleux puisque c'est de
l'inventivité manifeste
sur le fait de verser les primes aux
entreprises alors c'est exactement ce
que le gouvernement introduit en 2019
avec ma prime rénov via une possibilité
faite aux particuliers de désigner un
mandataire
qui est un artisan
potentiellement mais qui peut aussi
certains négociants sont des mandataires
certains industriels sont des
mandataires qui et c'est le problème que
je soulevé en début d'exposé sur le fait
que Lana a cessé de les rémunérer pour
tenter d'identifier les fraudeurs
ce dispositif et notamment aussi à
l'origine des faux comptes sur le site
de Lana puisque c'est en fait en se
déclarant mandataire et en récupérant
des identifiants France Connect que un
certain nombre de fraudeurs ont pu faire
verser sur leur compte des sommes qui
auraient dû revenir à des particuliers
quand tous ces deux œufs sur cet aspect
là la liberté de marché est totale c'est
à dire que certains opérateurs vont
faire des offres packagées qui vont
diminuer les prix d'autres vont choisir
de remettre une prime à un particulier
d'autres vont rémunérer l'artisan le
marché est assez créatif de ce point de
vue là donc il y a mais le la chose
existe et je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle ait
fait la preuve de son efficacité de
lutte contre la fraude j'ai même envie
de dire au contraire je pense qu'il y en
avait beaucoup moins
à l'époque du cite qu'il n'y en a
aujourd'hui
je voulais attirer votre attention
notamment par rapport à ce que disait
que choisir tout à l'heure sur le nombre
de contrôles qu'un chantier quand même
chantier est susceptible de connaître
en dehors d'un contrôle DGCCRF potentiel
et à posteriori ou sur dénonciation d'un
ou sur demande d'un consommateur mais un
même chantier peut faire l'objet d'un
audite RGE d'un contrôle Bureau Veritas
mandaté par Lana pour dans le cadre d'un
appel d'offre pour vérifier la
conformité des travaux réalisés avec les
critères de ma prime rénov plus de
specty ou d'un autre bureau de contrôle
coffretqué C2E pour le volet c2o ce qui
veut donc dire qu'on va payer trois
contrôles à peu près sur le même
référentiel
qui ce qui n'a pas à mon sens beaucoup
d'efficacité et il est probable qu'il y
a quelque chose à chercher de ce côté là
en fusionnant ces trois contrôles et en
se disant que la même personne et
l'auditeur RGE est en général
j'espère que
mieux rémunéré et
avec des garanties d'indépendance
supérieure au bureau de contrôle
par ailleurs existant en tout cas il me
semble que la fusion de ces trois
contrôles aurait un caractère
intéressant de pouvoir dire qu'un même
inspecteur peut s'assurer de la
conformité ces deux œufs regarder ce qui
vient de m'imprime rénov et
éventuellement faire un signalement un
organisme de qualification sur l'audit
RGE
en ayant peut-être deux trois quatre
heures à passer sur un chantier si ça
s'y prête alors que certains tarifs font
que évidemment le bureau de contrôle qui
est une entreprise privée cherche à
gagner sa vie ce qui est normal et du
coup un temps limité à y passer
et enfin je termine sur vous parliez de
mesure à l'étranger alors j'ai pas de
connaissances particulières là-dessus il
y a quand même une idée qui française
mais qui ne va pas être que française
j'imagine c'est que on a aujourd'hui et
elle n'est pas de moi il y a plusieurs
acteurs qui le réclament on a
aujourd'hui des compteurs communicants
qui Gaspard qui entend réel informe de
la consommation énergétique et qui du
coup donne un outil incroyable pour
savoir si oui ou non des économies
d'énergie ont été réalisées et il est
probable que un jour la rénovation
énergétique doit sortir de son
obligation actuelle de moyen c'est à
dire je vous aide si vous installez une
pompe à chaleur si vous mettez tant de
mètres carrés d'isolant etc et qu'elle
arrive à une obligation de résultat qui
sera je vous aide si vous avez réduit
votre consommation énergétique effective
de
20 à 25 30 35 % selon ce que les
pouvoirs publics choisiront et à ce
moment là la fraude va devenir beaucoup
plus compliqué et le dispositif beaucoup
plus efficace mais peut-être un peu plus
lent parce qu'évidemment il faudra
attendre de voir le résultat
très rapide sur le démarchage physique
en effet comme comme je vous le disais
on constate une corrélation entre
entreprise pratiquant le démarchage
physique donc le porte-à-porte et
malfaçon
et non achèvement des travaux donc et
s'agissant du démarchage téléphonique on
a enregistré une baisse du nombre de
signalements en la matière même si il
existe toujours donc on voit que son
interdiction malgré qu'elle soit
contournée et que certaines exceptions
réglementaires permettent de le faire
elle a une efficacité de fait et donc
dans le cas du démarchage physique on
pourrait supposer qu'elle en ait une
aussi
surtout que les pratiques dans le cas du
porte à porte sont particulièrement
[Musique]
agressive disons je vais jouer j'ai
utilisé le terme puisque on se retrouve
avec des consommateurs qui ont
l'impression d'avoir signé un bon
passage par exemple et qui en réalité
ont signé un bon de commande voire un
prêt
et donc ceux qui peuvent se trouver dans
des situations difficiles les prix
également pratiqués dans le cadre des
contrats
souscrits en porte-à-porte son
prohibitifs et ce qui est prescrit
notamment on a constaté ça sur les
pompes à chaleur et parfois sous
dimensionné par rapport au logement en
question donc
clairement les entreprises qui
pratiquent qui utilisent le démarchage
physique ont de mauvaises pratiques et
on voit un moyen un moyen simple et
efficace de limiter les frais dans la
matière
j'ai déjà dit
et du juste pour pour les prix entre
l'inverse le versement direct et le
versement dit intermédié donc que ça
soit de ces deux œufs avec une remise en
bas de facture ou un mandataire etc
sans avoir un chiffre précis comme on le
versement est direct il y a moins de
risque de fraude parce qu'en général les
gens sont beaucoup plus avertis quand
ils font ça en fait c'est souvent les
consommateurs malheureusement qui sont
démarché par des primes intermédiaires
en disant c'est zéro euro parce que
c'est intermé parce que si c'est zéro
heureux c'est que personne ne paye soit
que en fait personne ne paye en direct
c'est qu'il y a quelqu'un derrière qui
va payer donc souvent c'est un objet etc
et c'est à ce moment-là qu'il y a qu'un
qui a plus de de problèmes de
d'information et de et de et de et de
comparaison etc en comparer rarement une
offre gratuite c'est un peu compliqué à
concevoir après sur les sur le je veux
juste revenir sur sur les quelques
solutions sur les textes aujourd'hui on
a encore je
on a encore des textes frappés d'une
certaine naïveté de de fait c'est-à-dire
quand on fait on a des textes qui qui
créent de fait un des conditions de
phrase ils sont pas si imaginatifs que
ça je vois que vous l'aurez accorder
beaucoup beaucoup d'intelligence et je
ils ont pas dénué de d'intelligence
certes mais je pense que les textes font
que on a la capacité de frauder donc en
fait on a la capacité de de si on a la
capacité de de de d'avoir un auditeur
qui qui nous appartient qui va nous qui
va nous faire un audit enfin un audit
complètement falsifié sur la date puis
ensuite
exagéré sur les économies d'énergie
parce qu'on a la possibilité de le faire
parce que rien ne l'interdit et ensuite
on a un audit qui nous dit vous allez
avoir 40 000 euros d'aide pour des
travaux qui vont me coûter 20000 euros
je me demande même parfois si c'est
vraiment en fait c'est frauduleux dans
le sens où moralement c'est frauduleux
je me demande même parfois mise à part
le démarchage qui en fera une loi et
qu'il faut il faut être il faut séduire
là-dessus quand on a quand on a ça on
est on si on enquête bien on est frotte
du le mais quelque part on a profité
d'un
dispositif et et je me demande quand il
regarde devant la glace c'est fraudeur
dont on parle est-ce qu'ils ont
l'impression de frauder ils ont
l'impression d'optimiser quelque chose
donc je vraiment il y a un sujet pour
moi de de rétro-ingénierie des textes
pour préparer dis en fait ce texte là va
faire l'objet de fraude demain on sort
l'accompagnateur rénov on sait
pertinemment qu'il va y avoir des
accompagnateurs rénovs à la sotte
d'entreprise qui vont venir juste
valider ce que va vouloir installer
l'entreprise on le sait pertinemment
donc ça sert à rien de se dire que
potentiellement ça n'arrivera pas ça ça
sert à rien de se dire non plus que
potentiellement sur la MO ma prime
adapte ou là on parle de personnes âgées
qu'on veut maintenir à domicile et qui
sont d'une vulnérabilité extrême ça sert
à rien de se dire que c'est un mot va
avoir une morale exemple l'air ça ne
sert à rien il faut se dire déjà qu'il y
a des potentiel fraude et que il faut se
préparer il faut avoir des textes pour
se préparer deuxième élément c'est que
aujourd'hui en fait ce qu'on constate
nous c'est que les moyens qui sont c'est
des moyens colossaux de contrôle
un seul bureau de contrôle on en fait
30000 par an de contrôle dans la
profession il doit avoir entre entre au
moins en moins 150000 200 000 contrôles
c'est donner la contrôle ne sont pas une
une matière première à ma connaissance
pour pour par exemple à des CRF pour
pour ou kalibat etc aujourd'hui kalibat
pour renouveler votre RGE
[Musique]
je parle je précise le français on est
en moyen de lui offrir un guichet à côté
de lui alors imposant lui de passer à ce
guichet là d'avoir une société d'espace
de de espèce de d'attestation de passage
là-bas où on va l'informer sur les
potentiels fraudes dont il sera victime
s'il fait s'il donne suite à un devis un
devis alléchant certes mais mes
frauduleux quand même et donc si on a
ses moyens si on n'a pas ses moyens là
il faut que ce soit il faut s'appuie sur
le privé alors il faut être d'une
extrême vigilance sur l'indépendance
réelle et pas supposée pas affiché de
ces acteurs là qui soit l'accompagnateur
et neuve qui soit l'auditor énergétique
et qu'il soit le bureau de contrôle donc
c'est vraiment un élément pour moi qui
est central si on fait des faux tiers de
confiance on produit des fausses
espérances etc et on on fait on tourne
en rond sur sur la lutte contre la
fraude et et par ailleurs dans dans la
rénovation globale je m'inscris désolé
désolé mais je m'inscris en faux par
rapport à au fait de dire que dans la
Réunion sanguin fraude mais c'est tout
le contraire l'enlève son globe c'est le
boulevard de fraude alors il ressemble
notamment dit de 2021 c'est un boulevard
de fraude c'est plus le pnc2e qui
détermine le niveau de ces deux œufs
c'est c'est l'auditeur je m'explique
quand vous avez une maison sur
Geoportail elle fait 100 m². si vous
avez isolé 50 mètres carrés et que vous
dites que vous avez 200 m², on peut vous
croire et et votre fraude elle est
limitée à 50 mètres carrés d'isolation
et et encore ça se contrôle facilement
etc en revanche dans un audit quand vous
dites que vous allez générer 80%
d'économie et que vous partez d'une
situation initiale qui est c'est plus
l'alphabet c'est Z dans les audits c'est
plus FG en fait de fait c'est vous qui
déterminez auditeur il y a eu il y a eu
une fois sans des auditeurs on est passé
d'à peu près une centaine à 1100 à 1200
je préfère un calcul mathématique mais
il y a une enfin une vraie développement
de cette filière là et quand vous fait
quand vous dites qu'il y a 8 Go de C2E
l'équivalent de 60000 euros par exemple
de Dead et ben vous vous le dites à un
artisan qui qui est qui est pas autre
que votre maison mère d'ordre et que
ensuite vous allez demander un contrôle
à quelqu'un qui va qui va être
complaisant avec vous vous avez en fait
vous avez un vrai boulevard de de de de
fraude à la rénovation globale qui n'est
pas une rénovation globale en réalité
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous prenez un
réaction globale je je nous on a fait on
a fait des statistiques etc la
rénovation globale c'est quoi c'est une
pompe à chaleur il nous a la nation
obligatoire c'est pas les traitements en
fait ce que on tente tout le monde quand
on pardonner son globale il entend le
traitement des interfaces entre par
exemple les les les ouvertures et
l'isolation
iTele tout le monde entend qu'on va
comme comme un des reportages France 2
le décrivé avec vraiment un traitement
des interfaces des ponts thermiques etc
c'est pas du tout le cas c'est un cumul
de 2z avec une démultiplication de LED
par deux trois quatre etc si on avait
maintenu l'isolation 1 € avec une pack
et 1 € en ça coûterait moins cher à
l'État et deux on arrête on se raconte
pas des histoires avec une rénovation
globale qui n'en est pas une en réalité
donc ça c'est c'est vraiment le le et
encadrer ce rôle de prescripteur dans la
rénovation globale qui est l'auditeur et
demande l'accompagnateur rénove et et et
et absolument central à mon avis il faut
le retirer la capacité de calculer des
aides parce que parce que qui dit en
fait vous pouvez pas décentralisation là
le calcul LED qui par milliers d'euros
ça me paraît dangereux et en fait la
pratique si une enquête il y a sur la
rénovation globale va va le révéler
et et donc il y a comment
bien documenté
et sur la massification se termine par
ça sur la massification versus lutte
contre la fraude moi je vous dis en fait
ça dépend ce qu'on veut massifier si on
veut massifier la fraude il faut moins
lutter contre la fraude parce que ce
massif ira de nature si on veut vraiment
massifier la rénovation énergétique
alors il faut absolument lutter achat de
manière acharnée contre la fraude parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand vous êtes un
opérateur économique normal que vous
êtes un opérateur économique qui ne peut
pas faire de démarche à téléphonique en
fait qui du coup qui dit pas des marchés
définies dit un coup de d'acquisition
parce que c'est les sociétés
commerciales elles veulent
commercialiser une offre et donc dit un
coup d'acquisition qui est beaucoup plus
important parce que si vous faites un
démarchage avec un call center si tu as
l'étranger ça vous coûtera vachement
moins cher que qu'une vraie entreprise
qui va avoir qui va avoir envie de de
d'être attractif etc d'installer une
marque et de faire de la pub à la télé
etc c'est beaucoup plus cher et donc en
vous perdez en compétitivité sur le
démarchage téléphonique ensuite comme
vous optimisez pas vous les aides etc si
vous perdez au quotidien sur
l'optimisation des aides 3 vous faites
des bons travaux vous perdez en
compétitivité là dessus
4 vous faites des contrôles internes etc
parce que vous avez le souci de faire de
la qualité 5 vous faites un SAV parce
que vous êtes sérieux etc etc donc ce
qui fait que en fait quand vous êtes un
opérateur économique sérieux vous êtes
parfois c'est le paradoxe mais parfois
par l'écosystème ou par le dispositifs
etc des favoriser par rapport à un
fraudeur il passe de 100 personnes quand
c'est le boom du isolation à 1 € ou
d'une bac à trois personnes dans un
bureau une autre prise sérieuse elle
recrute des gens elle les forme elles
met du temps etc et quand on fait un
Stop and Go sur une aide parce que on
lutte contre la fraude elle se elle est
mise à mal donc il faut lutter de façon
acharner sur la fraude pour permettre à
ces acteurs là d'être au moins à égalité
de chance j'ai envie de dire c'est
vraiment le truc que je peux espérer
c'est qu'il soit égal quelque chose avec
les fraudeurs pour ensuite être j'espère
favorisé par rapport à des fraudes voilà
le monsieur J'ai excusez-moi je voudrais
juste ajouter un point j'ai eu pas mal
de évidemment nous sommes un média pour
les artisans au départ donc j'ai eu pas
mal d'artisans au téléphone notamment
sur ces sujets là
et beaucoup m'ont dit dans des gens
qualitatifs très sérieux ancien fils
d'artisan voilà cette image qu'on a de
l'excellence artisanale beaucoup m'ont
dit qu'il n'était plus RGE d'ailleurs ça
se voit dans les chiffres
que ils avaient renoncé aux aides qu'il
faisait les travaux dans les avec toute
leur excellence tout leur savoir et tout
leur cœur toute leur toute l'estime
qu'ils ont pour leurs clients mais qu'il
quittaient le dispositif RGE
que donc leurs clients n'avait plus
droit à ma prime rénov mais que de toute
façon ils ont une clientèle aisée qui
n'est pas spécialement éligible à ma
prime rénov donc ça ne les privait pas
beaucoup et que si vraiment le client
était très informé des 2000 euros de ces
deux œufs auxquels il aurait droit sur
les 20000 euros de travaux et bien il
lui faisait une remise sur son devis et
qu'il s'en sortait comme ça donc il y a
quand même un
risque aussi élevé on vous parliez de
perte de confiance des consommateurs
elle est réelle mais il y a aussi une
perte de confiance d'un tissu économique
dont parlait monsieur Jadid sérieux
impliqué et qui se détache des
dispositifs publics parce que parce que
il n'y croit plus et qu'il voit leur
faible efficacité et qu'il voit qui il
favorise
alors je crois qu'elle est prendre mon
toget qui voulait poser une question
quand on remarque à l'instant va
relativiser voire annihiler complètement
la question que je voulais vous poser si
ce n'est la proposition que j'allais
faire d'abord merci pour vos
interventions c'est très intéressant
très riche surtout quand on n'est pas
spécialiste c'est c'est mon cas je
m'interrogeais à partir de votre
présentation monsieur Roussel
sur la
question de la de la de la normalisation
du contrôle est-ce que le processus de
résonance de rénovation énergétique il
est susceptible d'une normalisation je
parle pas du RGE des normes qui vont
avec etc je parle du processus lui-même
qui permettrait à des points critiques
de faire de procès de procéder à du
contrôle alors du contrôle externe
vous avez je crois évoqué les trois
types de ces vous qui avez les trois
types de contrôle possible ou du
contrôle interne
hypodyte interne comme ça existait dans
certains entreprises qui sont certifiées
sur des différences ou autre
justement pour produire pour produire de
la quelque part de la confiance aussi
voilà et pouvoir attester du respect
d'une qualité de prestation et et des
normes qui vont avec puisque j'ai
compris qu'il y avait il y avait une
énorme technique de recommandations et
puis il y avait une norme ISO aussi qui
qui composait le référentiel RGE
non oui bon c'est ce que disent les
documents voilà donc ma question
ma question elle est
peut-être pas justifiée ou fondée mais
ma question c'est de voilà à travers des
à travers des audits propres à
l'entreprise elle-même ou produit par
l'extérieur est-ce qu'on est susceptible
mais de
pas de surveiller mais de maîtriser un
peu mieux le processus global de
rénovation énergétique
alors on va prendre la question aussi de
Sabine Draxler et après on vous laissera
répondre oui merci beaucoup
monsieur Debias tout à l'heure vous
parliez du déficit de compétences des
artisans ou des diagnostiquers et c'est
vrai j'ai lu un article qui était
consacré à ce sujet là dans Que Choisir
alors j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur la
prise en compte par justement les DPE
des caractéristiques du patrimoine bâti
qui a une valeur historique ou
architecturale avec des spécificités on
va dire hygrohermique particulière qui
lui sont propres et également sur les
matériaux les techniques qui sont à leur
préconisés et dont on sait qui sont qui
sont inadaptés est-ce que ce type de
bâti pour vous justement correctement
pris en compte et est-ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas je me suis dit ça en vous
écoutant estimez qu'en fait le DPE
actuellement
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas estimer qui
relève d'une forme de tromperie puisque
finalement il ne va pas refléter les
réalités des performances de ce type de
bâti il va générer des préconisations
qui vont qui vont provoquer des des
dégâts
là je pense notamment aux polystyrène
sur le pont de bois ou même des
démolitions puisque finalement vous
allez avoir des gens qui vont renoncer à
faire des travaux et derrière on sait
qu'actuellement dans le cas d'usane vous
allez avoir des promoteurs qui vont
arriver et qui vont affecter une
moins-value à des bâtis comme ça
racheter les terrains et démolir les
maisons alors on peut tout penser quand
je vous écoute je me dis mais tout est
possible quoi
fallait
alors Monsieur debier puisque vous avez
directement été interpellé par Madame
Draxler on n'a pas de dossier
particulier vous parlez surtout des
bâtiments qui ont une valeur
architecture
niche particulière par contre sur la la
confiance dans le DPE ça s'appelle
diagnostic en fait c'est une étiquette
énergie c'est pas un diagnostic comme le
médecin qui dit voilà vous avez tel
problème à tel endroit et telle solution
pour réparer
donc dans les pour les consommateurs il
y a souvent une difficulté à comprendre
la différence entre ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui diagnostic et puis un vrai
diagnostic avec des projets de travaux
ça c'est une première chose je vais
revenir sur une problème de confiance et
puis de
d'arnaque etc nous quand on parle quand
on traite des litiges on voit le bas de
l'échelle dans les résultats si on fait
tout à l'heure on a parlé surtout de
fraude et puis d'arnaque ça concerne un
pourcentage de
travaux donc pour nous c'est environ
10000 dossiers on n'a pas fait le
pourcentage pour savoir ce que ça
représente par contre il faudrait pas
penser qu'il y a d'un côté uniquement
l'arnaque en bas de l'échelle et puis
tout à fait en haut les travaux
parfaitement réalisés dans Negawatt vous
a dit que ça représentait 5% 5% des
travaux de rénovation globale arrivait à
un niveau
correct disons qui est normal pour
arriver aux objectifs 2050 entre les
deux il y a tous les échelons entre le
zéro et le 10
donc entre les deux on a un problème
d'efficacité des travaux et puis de
confiance des consommateurs parce que
jusqu'à présent il y a pas de garantie
de résultats je crois quelqu'un l'a dit
tout à l'heure il y a pas de garantie de
résultats sur les travaux nous quand on
emporte quand on va faire réparer la
voiture chez le mécanicien pour régler
le moteur on aimerait bien que à la
sortie la voiture consomme 5 litres au
sang comme c'est prévu si elle continue
à consommer 10 litres on va pas être
satisfait alors il y a une difficulté
pour mesurer les résultats donc et
là-dessus on comprend tout à fait ce que
vous a dit Olivier Sidler c'est lui qui
l'a dit dans la Table Ronde des
associations
il refusait la garantie de résultats
c'est pourtant un professionnel
ultra sérieux qui est une référence et
donc on sait sur quoi il s'appuie il
s'appuie sur le fait que selon l'usage
que l'on fait il va y avoir d'énormes
différences qui peuvent aller de 50 100%
ou plus de différence dans la facture
donc il faudrait trouver un instrument
de mesure qui permettent de mesurer
cette garantie de résultats donc ça
reste à mettre au point en faisant par
exemple un DPE avant un DPE après mais
de meilleure qualité que ce qui existe
aujourd'hui parce que on a vérifié que
les pays d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas
fiables
et ça permettrait de
d'améliorer la confiance des
consommateurs et puis ça permettrait au
niveau de l'État aussi
d'arriver à quelque chose de de plus
efficace puisque on vise la sobriété
énergétique 2050 si depuis des années on
fait des travaux qui sont pas efficaces
forcément en 2050 on va pas arriver de
très bons résultats
alors c'est quelqu'un souhaiterait
répondre à la question de Franck
Montauger sur les contrôles ou
répondre sur sur
je voulais sur les contrôles qui sont
menés par par l'entreprise évidemment
dans une entreprise est par exemple ils
ont 9001 elle doit faire des contrôles
internes etc et c'est très bien ainsi je
pense qu'on traite moins du sujet de la
fraude que du sujet de l'amélioration de
la qualité
réelle ou perçue par du client et donc
c'est ça c'est on est vraiment sur le la
partie de l'iceberg qui est qui est la
vertueuse donc c'est c'est c'est moins
c'est moins le sujet mais mais
évidemment que si si c'est fait c'est ça
va dans le bon sens après sur les
contrôles fait par des tiers du moment
en fait 601 indépendant et impartiot
c'est-à-dire là alors oui c'est efficace
donc en fait quand on contrôle de façon
très impartiale très impartiale et et
très et indépendante une entreprise on
est capable de lui dire là ça va pas là
ça va pas là ça va pas et ça permet
d'améliorer les choses parce que c'est
c'est pas en fait il y a pas d'un côté
les fraudeurs qui sont donc au fond et
de côté les gens honnêtes qui sont
confort on a beaucoup de pédagogie à
faire pour pour que pour que pour que
des mêmes des entre guillemets des
artisans anciens etc puis ça améliorer
un certain nombre de pratique et sans
qui ont été qui ont évolué mais ça sans
que qu'ils soient nécessairement
informés ensuite vous avez dans les dans
la panoplie des contrôles avec des
contrôles qui sont au niveau de
l'entreprise ça c'est c'est par exemple
le RGE c'est un label qui permet de
certifier une entreprise ça ne certifie
pas chantier par chanter il faut pas
faire croire mais parce qu'en fait même
la dénomination elle est parfois un peu
le reconnu garant environnement c'est
une certification de l'entreprise c'est
c'est comme si on vous dit vous êtes
sortis ISO 9001 donc vous faites que de
la qualité c'est faux c'est en fait vous
avez un système de management de la
qualité parce que vous avez un système
pardon excusez-moi par rapport à ce que
vous dites la peau pour qu'on soit sûr
de de se comprendre moi quand je regarde
les textes
je vois que RGE repose sur deux normes
une norme française une norme ISO
c'est écrit noir sur rouleau
on est vraiment dans des processus qui
sont pas forcément des processus globaux
mais qui sont des processus propres à la
conduite d'un chantier
incluant y compris l'accompagnement du
maître d'ouvrage dans le processus c'est
à dire de du départ du tout départ du
diagnostic à la limite jusqu'à la à la
livraison finale terminale donc voilà et
du coup on se convient certifié c'est
votre capacité votre système de manœuvre
c'est pour ça que vous je vous ai parlé
avec l'ISO 9000 ans c'est votre capacité
à avoir un processus qui qui est censé
générer de la qualité mais on vient pas
certifier vos chantiers on vient pas
dire votre chantier et confort on vient
de dire en gros que vous avez des
processus de formation des processus de
réalisation et de contrôle interne qui
permettent de renouvelle de 4 ans
[Musique]
la belle le fait
c'est ce que disent les textes sur la
base d'un chantier en cours ou achevé
de trois chantiers que vous choisissez
en général
donc on est vraiment dans un voilà et
d'où ma question qui était de savoir si
par rapport au processus de déroulement
des chantiers il n'y a pas des points
critiques
que vous connaissez certainement sur
lesquels vous vous appuyez pour faire
peut-être vos contrôles enfin je sais
pas quelle est la source et la source
des contrôles que vous notez que vous
développez il y a pas des points
critiques qui qui justifient bon voilà
qu'on regarde d'un peu plus près ce qui
se passe je dirais dans le dans le cours
de la vie d'une entreprise et des
chantiers qui sont réalisés voilà c'est
un peu sale elle est un peu difficile à
formuler la question ou la proposition
est simple d'où ma proposition de vous
dire quand on contrôle chantier par
chantier par des acteurs privés ou de
haut public ou ou peu importe qui sont
dès qu'on contrôle chantier par chantier
il faut pouvoir informer tous les
acteurs qui sont liés à cette Qualibat
en l'occurrence pour le RGE
l'état de de avec les différents
services qui sont là pour lutter la fin
de la fraude etc c'est pour ça que je
vous parlais de coordination des efforts
parce que nous on contrôle vous prenez
une entreprise quelconque moi je peux
vous dire j'ai fait 50 contrôle sur
l'entreprise il y a la moitié qui sont
pas confort mais le RG n'est pas inform
projet travaux de chantier
il a pas le loisir de
tenter un contrôle ou de souhaiter un
contrôle c'est pas possible ça ou alors
il le fait c'est pas possible ça alors
soit il a une plainte consommateurs et
il imagine après ce qui est traité de
soit il s'adresse à des à des par
exemple des experts des experts des
experts du bâtiment etc il peut il peut
effectivement le faire donc en faut-il
c'est des chantiers éclairs une PAC
aujourd'hui installée par par une
entreprise par lambda c'est une journée
c'est des chantiers éclairs et vous avez
la facture les aides sont versées et
puis et puis et puis c'est en fait c'est
pas quelque chose qui est la rénovation
globale qui est censée être un processus
global etc vous arrivez vous avez une
journée pour isoler une journée pour
faire la Pâques et et c'est fini et donc
ça laisse pas le temps de réfléchir etc
et de se dire bah tiens il est en train
de me flouter donc peut-être que je vais
déclencher un contrôle
alors peut-être pour terminer madame Guy
je voulais juste préciser une chose
c'est qu'effectivement la dgcf
intervient véritablement en fait sur les
pratiques commerciales donc nous
contrôlons pas en fait la bonne
réalisation des chantiers
c'est le ministère de la transition
écologique qui est plus particulièrement
compétent dans ce domaine là il faut
juste quand même préciser deux choses
la première c'est que bien entendu du
consommateur qui ne serait pas satisfait
de la réalisation c'est des travaux a
également la possibilité s'il connaît
l'organisme de certification
qualibates qualitétionnaire ou autre
qui effectivement a délivrer le label
RGE de le signaler pour que cet
organisme diligente en fait un audit et
on sait que qualification ce sont
mobilisés
de manière assez conséquente ces
dernières années justement pour
notamment
le cas échéant prononcer les sanctions
contre les contre les opérateurs
mal intentionnés et par ailleurs donc on
l'a dit un peu plus tôt le dispositif
mon appareil mon accompagnateur Renov
qui donc doit être déployé vise
justement à permettre aux consommateurs
d'être d'avoir une expertise de disposer
d'une expertise tout au long en fait du
parcours
et notamment d'avoir éventuellement des
signaux d'alerte de la part de cet
accompagnateur s'il y a des difficultés
dans la réalisation des travaux
bon je vais vous laisser je vous laisse
avec le rapporteur je suis obligé de
j'ai une autre réunion je vous remercie
très sincèrement voilà d'avoir participé
à cette table ronde qui était très
intéressante la preuve c'est que elle a
duré fort longtemps et c'est très bien
il y a eu beaucoup d'échanges je pense
que vous avez encore beaucoup de choses
à dire alors vous allez pouvoir
peut-être des compléter auprès du
rapporteur sinon ceux qui n'ont pas fait
parvenir les réponses aux questionnaire
que dans la diffusé n'hésitez pas à en
faire le retour auprès de la Commission
en tout cas merci beaucoup et bonne
soirée
la parole dans une petite question
complémentaire sur les justement sur les
contrôles c'est vrai que quand on a
auditionné Lana elle nous disait qu'il y
avait à peu près qui faisait à peu près
10% des contrôles sur la masse de
chantier fin de d'être qui pouvait avoir
si on prend ma prime rénove je crois
qu'on a entre 600 et 700000 dossiers
est-ce que vous avez une idée d'une
globale sur ces 600 ou 700 000 qui
effectivement peuvent être juste une
pompe à chaleur ou qui peuvent être des
rénovations globales enfin on a de tout
le nombre de contrôles en fait qui peut
y avoir par rapport à ce nombre
assaisissant ou 700 000 parce que c'est
vrai qu'en plus on a différents types de
contrôle mais est-ce qu'on a une idée de
ce que ça représente quoi bon en gros
quel est le nombre à l'inverse de de
chantier qui ne sont pas du tout
contrôlés en fait
je n'ai pas d'informations particulières
alors Lana fait des contrôles
déjà des vérifications téléphoniques
auprès des particuliers et ensuite les
contrôles sur chantier non on n'a pas
d'ordre de grandeur mais 10%, ça me
semble être un maximum je pense je pense
pas qu'elle est après c'est tous une
question budgétaire c'est à dire que
chaque contrôle est
rémunéré un bureau Veritas sur un tarif
fixé par appel d'offres
donc
la nana n'a jamais que les moyens qu'on
lui donne mais pourtant ça me paraît
être mais parce que si si c'est
dupliquer sur dans l'isolation par
exemple c'est 10% dans la pompe à
chaleur c'est 10% dans le C2E donc je
pense qu'on est pas loin des 10 %, mais
on n'a pas de données il faudra c'est
cette proportion là mais encore une fois
si
un contrôle C2E
critique ou avec des points d'alerte
était transmis à Lana alors je crois que
ça commence à se faire entre le pnc2e
pour dire ben il y a un peu de ma prime
rénov ça vaut le coup d'aller jeter un
œil
et que calibat ou kalitenaire en été
aussi informé et ça ce n'est pas fait
pour qu'éventuellement il puisse eux se
diriger des auditeurs comme je disais
tout à l'heure si c'est trois contrôles
étaient en fait un seul il y a des
chances que
force soit mutualisé et donc plus
efficace
tous les chantiers soient contrôlés ce
qui est matériellement impossible à
moins d'avoir des moyens qui m'ont quasi
limité et puis chanter peuvent être très
courts mais si on veut lutter contre la
contre la faute serait l'un des moins
les plus efficaces mais concrètement
est-ce que ce serait enfin voilà comment
est-ce qu'on comment est-ce qu'on peut
faire sur sur ces sujets là on peut
prospecter par auprès du consommateur et
puis est-ce qu'au final ça peut pas dans
certains cas aller à
son désavantage ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est lui qui a bénéficié
d'aide financière et il s'avère qu'il y
a une problématique qu'on constate a
postériori sur les travaux est-ce qu'il
va être contraint de rembourser voilà et
c'est comme tout à l'heure on avait le
débat versement direct versement
intermédié oui effectivement il y a un
dispositif qui peut être plus plus enfin
qui permet d'éviter davantage la fraude
moi j'ai juste en mémoire plusieurs cas
avec ma prime rénov par exemple ou des
consommateurs seront approchés de de
professionnels ils ont fait un devis le
devis est envoyé à Lana qui est validé
on a le tampon les travaux sont réalisés
ils payent les travaux sauf qu'après ils
envoient la facture et le même
contrôleur se rend compte que oui mais
effectivement il y a un petit souci
finalement dans la facture qui pourrait
être totalement identique au devis mais
il y a une mauvaise appréciation du
devis au départ et bien dans des courses
le consommateur une finie n'a pas son
aide financière
donc comment est-ce que l'on fait dans
ces éléments là alors même qui
comptaient sur 5000 ou 2000 euros
supplémentaires donc ça qui il y a
peut-être un système qui est moins pire
que l'autre effectivement on n'a pas la
panacée effectivement sur le sur le RGE
j’écoutais ce que ce que chacun disait
également sur ce qui semble se passer à
l'étranger à savoir en fin de compte il
y a pas de la belle et on réalise les
faits le contrôle à posteriori quoi à la
rigueur pourquoi pas parce que comme
souvent d'outils la problématique n'est
pas l'outil lui-même la personne qui
l'utilise sur la pour le DPE après et
donc de fait si on doit se focaliser et
contrôler ces entreprises ont bien la
belle RJ et puis après contrôler leur
chantier pourquoi ne pas contrôler
directement le chantier
on peut s'interroger ce serait
intéressant de voir effectivement
comment ça se passe en Allemagne ou dans
d'autres pays là d'autres façons le
label RGE pour le consommateur et
l'invisible voilà enfin il a pas de
connaissances réelles on est sensibilise
sur le sujet mais c'est pas forcément un
plus et
voilà donc sur ce sujet je pense
qu'effectivement c'est un peu peu
problématique sur la défiance du
constructeur vis-à-vis des artisans ou
c'est pas uniquement sur les travaux
d'économie d'énergie envers la plupart
des métiers avec la crainte de l'arnaque
ne serait-ce que à plombier un
électricien il y a quand défiance des du
consommateur sur ce type de
professionnel parce que il y a la
crainte de se faire avoir vous avez
pléthore maintenant de personnel qui se
de professionnels qui se disent expert
sur ça sur la rénovation ou soit sur les
travaux de dépannage à domicile tout
simplement parce qu'ils arrivent à
coller du papier peint droit et quand
vous discutez avec ne serait-ce que des
syndics par exemple ils ont de très
grandes difficultés à trouver du
personnel le temps pour faire des
travaux on va dire d'entretien courant
dans les immeubles qu'ils gèrent et
qu'au pire les premiers chantiers sont
plus ou moins propres et là je parle pas
de rénovation globale le gros opérations
je parle vraiment pour quasiment du
dépannage mais après effectivement la
catastrophe donc j'irai cette défiance
elle est
généralisée si je puis dire énormément
de professions liées au dépannage vous
l'avez comme type c'est effectivement ce
que c'est un bon plombier ou un bon
électricien vous avez toujours la
crainte de de vous faire arnaquer en
quelque sorte sur le DPE
on en est à ça troisième réforme je
crois je sais plus il est censé
systématiquement être plus performant
que le précédent je redis ce que ce que
j'avais indiqué il y a quelques minutes
à savoir le problématique c'est pas
forcément l'outil c'est la personne qui
l'utilise et là on continue d'avoir les
enquêtes effectivement de mes confrères
l'ont bien démontré ou pour un même bien
on a trois quatre étiquettes différentes
c'est vrai que la problématique réside
dans l'appréciation l'utilisation que va
faire le le professionnel des éléments
en sa possession également de sa
connaissance du sujet des éléments
techniques ou non de l'immeuble et ce
qui va bien prendre en compte tout ces
points là c'est vrai qu'on est sur
l'exemple que vous souleviez on est sur
les immeubles classés Monument
historiques alors là je vous renvoie
avec les critères de décence ou c'est
logement vont être considérés sont déjà
considéré indécent depuis le 1er janvier
2023 s'ils ont une performance
énergétique une consommation super à 450
kWh d'énergie finale donc ce qu'on
appelle le G+ partie de l'étiquette g
1er janvier 2025 c'est intégralité
l'étiquette LG qui va sauter au point de
janvier 2028 c'est intégralité de
l'étiquette F
même si vous démontrez que vous êtes
dans l'incapacité de procéder à ces
rénovations énergétiques vous allez
quand même être considéré comme un
dessin
donc comment est-ce que l'on fait vous
avez des professionnels qui vous disent
que pour les logements qui sont situés
pardon les chambres de bonnes sous les
combles de le fait on ne peut pas les
améliorer parce que c'est en zinc de
façon donc on peut pas déposer et mettre
après des revêtements ou sinon si on
fait une isolation thermique par
l'intérieur ce qui peut être possible
lorsque vous êtes sur du sur de
l'historique même si c'est déconseillé
avec des problèmes techniques notamment
des
pratiques si c'est mal fait de pont
thermique vous allez empiéter sur votre
surface habitable il y a un risque votre
chambre de bonne finalement fasse moins
de 9 mètres carrés puis ne puisse plus
être loué puisqu'elle sera déclara
déclaré indécente vu qu'on est sur une
superficie minimale de 9 mètres carrés
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour organiser
pour harmoniser tous ces toutes ces
mesures là j'ai pas la seule solution
sur ça alors pour la problématique nos
gens sur l'obligation de rénovation
énergétique il y a un décret qu'en
préparation qui répond en partie en
partie et bien de façon imparfaite à ce
sujet là à savoir que le juge pourra pas
imposer la réalisation de travaux si le
logement est indécent dès lors que je
suis dans un immeuble classé monument
historique donc cela pourrait porter
atteinte à la solidité à structure même
du bâti à savoir que l'isolant créer une
pathologie sur l'immeuble
ça fait pas pour autant une dérogation à
l'obligation réalisée des travaux
d'économie d'énergie
tout à fait tout à fait
là je vois pas
et ben merci enfin je sais pas si vous
avez d'autres d'autres choses à ajouter
mais en tout cas merci pour l'ensemble
de vos de vos interventions et puis les
réponses à nos questions merci beaucoup